[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to Batman Beyond I'm Kevin Smith
I'm Marvin
oh my god this is the most people we've
ever had right here in this room at one
time and where are we folks we are at
the scum and villainy canteen on
Hollywood Boulevard in Hollywood
California put your hands together so
the folks who are at home know you are
real Wow
thanks for coming out but this is what
happens when you give away a free
[ __ ] movie
you are smart smart consumers for those
of you who have been here many times
welcome back for those of you have never
been here before
welcome this is a wonderful little cave
of a joint where we sit around talk
about all the things we love are not
involved in whatsoever except with our
fandom and support and [ __ ] like that
this week we're gonna spend a [ __ ] ton
of time talking about spider-man
obviously we've all seen it we're all
shooting webs over it I'm sure maybe
there's somebody in the room was like
[ __ ] it that'll be interesting as well
you know you'll see us beat that person
up but before we get to spider-man we've
got like a regular bunch of the show to
do so we'll be doing that and then we'll
launch into spider-man after that so
it's gonna be big chunky show this week
folks kick sit back and get ready man
there's lots to [ __ ] cover but before
we do that first we say hello to this
gentleman how the [ __ ] are you I'm good
man are you so good I was in Venice
Beach where I never [ __ ] go to man
and like I grew up in a beach town and
[ __ ] and I think that's why I never go
down there and when I got down there I
was like oh man I could live in a beach
town and then two minutes later I was
like [ __ ] up beach town oh god it's so
hot and like and I forget like I don't
really dwell in a world of a few layers
of clothing like I'd live in a multi
layer world I always wear a multi layers
hair I've always my wife wears pajamas
under [ __ ] pajamas like you know it's
it's just a pretty layered
world we're like you know [ __ ]
Mormons so when you go down to the beach
man like no one else lives like that
everybody's like dig out boobies out
like that the skinniest of [ __ ] claw
I forgot like beach culture is like I
came here to be nearly naked and so like
there was tons of [ __ ] nearly naked
people around meanwhile Jason Mewes and
I were down in Venice Beach to do a bit
for the show our friend Brian Quinn does
Impractical Jokers on truTV so we went
down there to shoot a piece as Jay and
Sanne Bob so I'm wearing the [ __ ] I'm
wearing the whole outfit the heavy ass
coat and [ __ ] like that everyone else
[ __ ] naked like all around me and
they looked at me like I was eccentric
I'm like none of you people are [ __ ]
wearing clothes so we shot a bit it was
real fun and whatnot Brian Quinn I've
known for years we were talking about
right before we shot this thing seems
real emotional he's like I can't believe
we're doing this because me and Jason
are on the 200th episode of the show and
I was like 200 [ __ ] episodes man
that's nuts and he goes and it started
as your intern because years ago like 24
years ago Brian Quinn worked at the view
askew offices he's the guy that first
set up the mail orders when people like
what are you selling him we were like
the idea of these movies I guess and
they're like no don't you have like
posters and [ __ ] and I was like we got a
bunch of Mallrats posters nobody wanted
and [ __ ] and they were like sell it so
we'd sign him and sell him send him out
Quinn would be the one who would package
him up and said man so he's with us way
back in the beginning and he got the
[ __ ] job because he you know early on
on the website like I was very active on
online like as far back as 95 and after
Mallrats came out I had a message board
at the askew website and Quinn was one
of the people that post it and so he put
up a post he's like I can't find the
Mallrats script book which kitchen-sink
did it had the script but was a lot of
pictures and kind of look like a big
comic book and so he's like I can't find
it in any bookstores and [ __ ] and so you
know I was like oh my god I got [ __ ]
200 because the movie flopped so I'll
sign one and send one to this kid and
[ __ ] I'm sure he'll dig it and stuff
nobody else in the world asked him for
this book so I did I signed it and I
wrote dear Brian give that this is the
story he told me sorry I forgot to
include this part he said not only could
he not find the book at a local
bookstore
the guy who ran the bookstore which was
at the mall said Kevin Smith
we wouldn't carry that he sucks and this
was [ __ ] in 1995 this guy was ahead
of the curve [ __ ] so oh my god he saw it
he was like you know you all think he's
important [ __ ] it I can see so did he
send a raven with this message I guess
right he's like I come from the future
so so he said Kevin Smith sucks so Quinn
had written that in his thing and so I
wrote in my inscription to Quinn dear
Brian give that bookstore dork some [ __ ]
love Kevin Smith not seriously just you
know the way that george RR martin
writes winter is coming in every book he
signs and it's not like he means it like
ron you know like it's just some [ __ ] to
write in a book so I just wrote like
[ __ ] you know if I can give that
bookstore dork some [ __ ] week later we
got a package at the office a little
envelope of [ __ ] padded envelope you
open it up had an audio cassette in it
because this was 1995 and we still used
those so we popped in the audio except
from Brian Quinn he's a cab listen to
this Brian Quinn thank you for the book
I loved it so much listen this Brian
Quinn so to pop in the cassette and
Brian apparently went back to the mall
to the bookstore and took me very
literally and so you hear this audio
cassette you can hear it you know it's
not you can find it on YouTube the
testee boys tell him Steve did well
which Brian Quinn does with Brian
Johnson and Walter Flannigan my friends
from comic book man very incestuous
little world we go those cats have it
tez D as their shows called has it
animated they have the audio and they
animated it so what you hear is the
sounds of a mall which for those who are
like what's that it was a place where
stores were once when we were kids
preceded Amazon what Amazon killed so
you can hear them all you hear the
bookstore traffic because it goes more
quiet than the mall and you hear him go
hey hey you remember me I came in last
week and I was looking for a Mallrats
book and the guy goes yeah I guess and
then he goes yeah yeah you said that
Smith sucks right and he goes I I don't
and he goes well Kevin Smith I told him
you said that
and he told me to come down here and
give the bookstore dork some [ __ ] and he
starts screaming and he's like screaming
at the guy goes what are you gonna do
and he's bringing a little Adam Sandler
and [ __ ] like that and you hear the guy
in the background going Jesus Christ get
out get out so we listen to that tape I
was like we have to hire that guy and we
brought him in and he worked for us from
like four years at the office and now
he's got his own [ __ ] TV show they're
up to 200 episodes and stuff so we went
out and shot a bit for him world weird
world of going full [ __ ] circle but
man my advice never wear a winter coat
Venice Beach [ __ ] ever Jesus so hot
how are you what you've been up to I've
been good it seems like the lesson in
that story is also the only other people
who go to the beach in layers of
clothing are homeless because they're
wearing everything they have that's true
that's true you took it to a dark
[ __ ] place but yeah that's true say
mm-hmm have any other social
observations to make Lenny Bruce can we
keep it fun ends and I thought maybe I
saw Toy Story 4 which wait hold on based
on that reaction doesn't sound like the
rest of them did how many people have
not seen to her story for okay I'm gonna
suppose do again because some people
just raise their hands on a podcast how
many people have not seen Toy Story
fourth put your hands together clap okay
how many people have seen Toy Story 4
put your hands up okay all right then
for those of you who haven't seen it
it's about toys
right like there's a cowboy and a space
[ __ ] spoilers god
I was worried like the bedrock spoiler
of it's about toys right so at this
point in the in the Toy Story saga yeah
you've had one two and three one as you
meet the toys two is they go on some
adventures three years they almost died
three is Schindler's toybox so [ __ ]
heartbreaking and at one point they're
all holding hands and going toward the
[ __ ] fire and you're like what the
[ __ ] like this is how it ends and then
it doesn't end that way but you were
like later on after the credits like it
was so beautiful it'd be metal if they
ended it the [ __ ] flames like there's
a home my friend Vincent Pereira who I
used to work at a quick stop in rst
video with he was big movie fan so we
want to see far and away the movie
bought Ron Howard and there's a point in
the movie where if you've never seen it
spoilers it's a [ __ ] 30-year old movie
or something where Tom Hanks character
like gets killed at the end Tom Cruise
Tom Cruise sorry not sorry thanks Tom
Cruise Wow Tom Cruise by bad it was one
of the Tom's anyway Tom Cruise gets
killed Nicole Kidman who was that his
wife is laying on top of him like cryin
and stuff and they do this point of view
shot where the camera lifts up like his
soul is dying and going to heaven and
[ __ ] and then she's like she finally in
the movie says she loves him she's like
I love you and the camera comes rushing
back at him and then Tom Cruise pops up
and [ __ ] happily-ever-after and [ __ ]
so we work at the video store at rst
video and Vincent prayer comes in one
day and he gives me a VHS tape and he
goes replace far and away with this
please and I said what is it he goes pop
it in I'll show you so he popped it in
went all the way to the [ __ ] credits
just before the credits rolled back and
it was Vinny's recut a far and away so
Tom Cruise lying on the ground dying
camera pulls up and [ __ ] like that
credits so we had three copies of far
and away and a third of the people that
saw far and away saw a different far and
away the two thirds of Leonardo man so
[ __ ] strange so in any of that yes
but [ __ ] the the Schindler's Toy Box
was a heartbreaker [ __ ] yes seemed like
a logical conclusions well I'm not
[ __ ] on the franchise I hope they
make a zillion but it did and but the
tag at the end of that like we're almost
gonna die everybody's fine with it
because we have friends they like Andy
gives them his box of toys to a young
girl and so the toys get to keep on
getting played with right um and and
they all like paint over the names and
their boots because every toy has the
name of the kid that loves them on their
boots and now it says bonny instead of
Andy and the assumption is that though
you know [ __ ] this will happen when
she grows up and the toys nobody will
ever throw them out they'll just get
handed off to strangers left and right
totally
toys 34 is a totally fun Toy Story movie
right it's like the little girl goes to
kindergarten her first day at
kindergarten she's super scared she
can't bring any toys with her cuz she's
gotta be a big girl and so she makes a
toy out of garbage which is adorable
because this is a suicidal toy made out
of a fork but she takes a spork and she
ties a pipe cleaner around it and gives
it a little like ice cream stick feet
and names it for key and for key thinks
he's trash because he's trash and so for
most of the movie he just wants to go to
the trash because he's trash and so like
Woody is on suicide watch for [ __ ] 40
where he says like trash trash trash and
he dives hims like no no no no trash
trash he's like holding his hand is like
you got a mint the adventure kicks off
proper when they're on this road trip
like we're going on around RV trip and
like four key jumps out of the [ __ ]
RV and what is like I gotta save her
he's Bonnie's favorite toy so he jumps
out also and it's a whole [ __ ] thing
but so it sounds like Toy Story 3 was
like where the Mo's existential toy
movie ever made in Toy Story 4 is like
hold my beer yes
old my millennial self-loathing beers
this trash and so and it also opens with
his bed about how bo-peep gets sort of
traded away in the beginning it's a
little prologue Oh is there yeah that
tell you where she went what she wasn't
in like three was for me I said whatever
happen to Bo peeps I don't know she gets
you know she gets older she gets given
away to some guy who then takes it to a
to a secondhand shop but it's this
tear-jerking sort of separation between
Woody and Bo Peep who kind of had this
sort of unresolved romance mmm we meet
Bo Peep again in this movie and she's
like a lost toy and the lost toys in
this movie like just live in the wild
like their Roman free like they don't
have kids they just like have their own
lives and have their own adventures and
it's and it becomes this this decision
for woody of do I need to go back to the
tour to the kid that's mine right or is
it possible for me to be happy living in
the wild and doing whatever I want and
being free lost toy with with Bo Peep
and that's the the basic sort of
philosophical crux in this movie and
there's all of the [ __ ] action scenes
that are great there's all of it this
sort of joy and Wonder there's a couple
of stuffed animals played by key and
Peele which are amazing there's Duke
kaboom which is a Canadian daredevil
played by Keanu Reeves doing his most
Keanu it's adorable it has been this
Canadian since [ __ ] what was the
hockey movie slot no not slap shot the
one with you know what's his name Rob
Lowe
Youngblood Wow he was cuz wasn't he he
was the goalie in Youngblood and he's
leaning into his french-canadian accent
what I assume is a French fake
french-canadian accent
unless he's from Quebec and that's a
real french-canadian oh I guess maybe he
might be [ __ ] see there's there's a
bunch of super fun [ __ ] and I really
really enjoyed it I took the kids and
they really loved it too and then I
started thinking about it because the
movie ends where you know Bo Peep
decides she convinces spoiler woody to
like live the free life with her
like all right excellent happy everybody
wins I'm like but okay so we don't need
we have characters who have like names
branded on them we have a whole
narrative that's about freedom versus
responsibility versus staying with the
people who put their names on your skin
and being able to just kind of like run
wild in the world and like is this like
a really deep meditation on like the
house Negro field negro dynamic did they
put that on the poster they shut down
cuz that would sell a ticket or to the
like Toy Story 4 has lost its mind if
you're not familiar with the house Negro
field negro dynamic it gets explored
quite a bit in both 12 years of slave
and Django Unchained but the idea that
during slavery there were two kinds of
slaves and the ones that worked in the
fields [ __ ] hated it and they're the
ones who worked in the house who had it
better than the ones in the field to the
point where if he worked in the house
long enough you got to believe that you
were invested in that well doing of that
house that house was are we good or we
alright monied anything else master I
remember Denzel speech from Malcolm X
right it's a big Malcolm X quote that he
just totally does and and and what the
field Negroes like I want a [ __ ] go
as soon as I can go I want to be free
this sucks let's jump over any fence
let's let's you know break the bonds and
let's find some way to get a life back
and so when you start thinking about em
in Tori story for like Bo Peep is
Harriet Tubman right Bo Peep was like
I'm gonna ferry these toys with the
brands on their feet into the free world
I'm gonna get them I'm gonna break your
shackles what do you need a kid what is
that kid doing for you it loves me who
loves you more than we do who loves you
more than your fellow toys what does
they ever done for you as awesome and I
just like Pixar the [ __ ]
mn you know I mentioned that on the
internet and the internet does what the
internet does yeah what what it internet
do the internet you know well it turns
out when you talk about race on the
Internet
it uh it doesn't go down that easy to
most of the internet who decided that I
see race and everything and then you
compound that with with Ming the
Merciless from last week and like I am a
Ming the Merciless it's kind of a Yellow
Peril trope in the thirties and forties
like it is kind of it's not even kinda
it's like totally racist like leave me
merciless alone but it's true I love it
you love a thing just know what it is
and so that's been the last like three
days for me it's just it's kind of like
you know it's it's that bit in and I
think it's duck amuck when when Daffy is
like pretending to know some of these
doctors predicted to be musketeer
there's a doctor it's been a lot of dogs
turned Perry spinning of morons I mean
here the Eye of Sauron has fallen upon
you it has I mean luckily I know the way
yeah so it's okay I've been down here
before in the future save any theories
for this room because it you know it
didn't play but nobody smashed a glass
on the floor
nobody stormed out of the room it seemed
to play well here maybe it goes down you
know they're coming off of this show
it's a warmer room yeah although the
Ming the Merciless stuff came out of the
last episode how bad was the blow back
for the Ming the Merciless
I mean it's all at this and I mean I
look I'm not [ __ ] god I'm not I don't
got skin in this game but like who's
fighting for like I [ __ ] love making
the Merciless is like man you don't even
[ __ ] know who Ming the Merciless is
like this you're talking about some
old-ass character very much so but you
know like and it is never as bad as it
has been right talking about this
because it was once upon a time I said
hey what if spider-man wasn't a white
guy and like I literally got death
threats oh he's really were you working
at the reporter at this now is at io9 I
was run over nine and they were they
were looking to cash
the new Peter Parker for what would be
the amazing spider-man and the roster of
the dudes they could have chosen was
like the most boring roster of mostly
British guys ever and they landed on a
pretty boring British guy like Andrew
Garfield it's like he's fine but kind of
unremarkable given the rest of that
[ __ ] [ __ ] right up second [ __ ] ran
up and I'm like why does he have to be a
white guy like what about Peter Parker
demands that he be white he's from a
broken home he lives in Queens
he's a nerd none of those things in fact
it probably argues against him being
white given all of that stuff right so
it's just asking the question what if
and then that became like this whole not
even tempest in a teacup cuz it was
tempest in a potion I call the FBI like
really yeah like snail mail letters
email letters all of that [ __ ] of just
like oh I'm gonna find where you live
cook I dare you to go to convention
i double-dog dare you to go to a
convention no yeah and then and then the
donald glover of it all like spun out of
that out of that story and a sec hey
Donald Glover should be spider-man i
McDonald we got that would be an amazing
idea that Donald Glover is like that's a
horrible idea because then he started
getting death threats because people
said you'd be a great spider-man and he
was like maybe I would and he wears like
those spider-man pajamas in community
and then he gets death threats and then
it was hey so maybe we should just stop
talking about spider-man for a bit hmm
maybe that's the thing but then Brian
Bendis sees the [ __ ] the childish
gambino [ __ ] was like hey you know it'd
be awesome
Miles Morales and then Miles Morales
gets to sort of I think there were also
a bunch of a [ __ ] pissed off people
about it to help that it was Miles
Morales I'm not black Peter Parker but
even still like that the goodness that
came out of that Booya Bay's of [ __ ] was
you eventually get spider-verse wait
where where's this all predate Miles
Morales comes from that you're saying
they're at Miles Morales hadn't been no
are you [ __ ] me
I mean I've heard you tell variations of
a story but of a story close to this but
I don't maybe I maybe have been high and
or maybe I'm high now and I'm just
airing it again and going what but like
really so that article predicated Bendis
creating Miles Browns are you [ __ ]
me do you get a [ __ ] piece I get I
get nothing but a woman go in my heart
every time I watched into the
spider-verse
that's [ __ ] fantastic man that [ __ ] I
was worth taking a little [ __ ] for man
you know I I've taken a lot of [ __ ] that
that was worth it how can I have the
[ __ ] that I've taken that is my favorite
[ __ ]
let's name your biography I believe my
favorite mark barnard story all right
speaking of mark barnard and man we've
got a ton of news oh to get to before we
even get to what we came to talk about
tonight which I'm bursting at the seams
to speak about but before we do that
good old Mark Barnard and bothered to go
to the Internet pull up some news that
we could talk about and digest this
evening give it up for Mark Barnard with
the news
[Applause]
good news
my other favorite game in the last week
on the Internet has been people saying I
know the show you and Kev are working on
it's this I've seen some guesses that
are like man you really think far too
much of me yeah I did I did actually see
a couple of right guesses though did you
I did I mean I didn't say like you're on
the money champ but now yeah a couple a
couple of people stumbled upon it really
yeah
one of them is not that we are doing the
Sandman because no but the Sandman is
[ __ ] coming to TV fine Sandman is
gonna get a [ __ ] show on Netflix this
is [ __ ] amazing man if you take me
back in time to like when I first bought
the issue one of salmon off the [ __ ]
spinner rack at a comic book store and
told me like when we read it we fell in
love with that book same way we fell in
love with Watchmen same way we fell in
love with preacher after afterwards when
that came out like we would sit there
and read and be like man wouldn't it be
cool if like HBO would do this like as a
series because you couldn't do it a
movie this story is too big if they
would just do it as an episodic man like
do the story of Sandman but like with
that many episodes and then they would
always talk about making a movie like
Joseph gordon-levitt for a 1-point was
attached to movie Roger a ver years ago
was attached to a movie you know and you
felt like great I'll watch that but that
story was so epic Neil Gaiman was such a
genius that story is so massive you
couldn't figure out how they were gonna
fit it into two hours but you're just
happy to see those concepts writ large
on the big screen but in your heart you
always wanted to see it long-form the
way it was meant to be finding this
information on the Internet man like cuz
first they announced it two days before
like it was you know it was rumor it was
we think this is happening sources say
this has happened and then Neil like
threw a little water on it by being like
I don't know like
like oh [ __ ] maybe it's not maybe it's
not gonna go to Netflix sounded like it
was happening but maybe not there but
then as of this morning I guess they
said hey it's [ __ ] Netflix it's
everything they told us who's it who
else is involved besides Neal Neal and
David Goyer are going to executive it's
a comic book project so gorya of course
must be involved Hollywood mandate his
involvement and Allan Heinberg is going
to write the pilot and show run that
name sounds familiar you wrote Wonder
Woman Wonder Woman yes and I'm comic
books didn't hate comic books he did
Young Avengers for Marvel did he create
Kate Bush she created Kate Bishop but
he's also been like I got it right
please Johnny you're on fire
but he's also spent a lot of time in TV
in the sort of Shawn diverse Grey's
Anatomy and always a crossover guy he's
a crossover guy it's something you're
familiar with a little bit but yeah like
it's Eric Eric Heiser our friend Eric
Heiser who wrote arrival was the most
recent guy to be hired to write the
movie version of it and he spent an hour
working on an hour a year working on it
and and at the end of that year he was
like you know this should be a TV show
like the best destiny for this is not as
a feature you can make it but you're
leaving so much of that what's great
about it on the table so don't even this
is leaning out for years I've been going
like oh my [ __ ] childhood is coming
to life on the big screen that's
absolutely true but now my late
adolescence in my early 20s are coming
to life on the big screen this is the
[ __ ] I was digesting right before I
started making my stuff right before I
made clerks I was [ __ ] balls deep in
Sandman and [ __ ] like that you don't get
to Dogma without Sandman first without
the work of Neil Gaiman so hearing that
they're doing a [ __ ] series hearing
that he's involved can you imagine when
he [ __ ] first wrote issue one way
back never thinking man like one day
they'll give us all the money in the
world to do this correctly and it's
gonna look as good as this book if not
[ __ ] better yeah
like we're there we're living in the
[ __ ] future man this is why [ __ ]
I'll pay
flicks money every month even if I never
[ __ ] watch it again because I'm like
[ __ ] Keats coming yeah I'll watch that
but like [ __ ] just keep making the
smart decisions that's so brilliant I
don't know how to [ __ ] that got out of
Warner Brothers though I mean that like
how did they let that go the prevailing
theory and it is just a theory because
nobody will comment really on the
numbers of it all is that Warner
Brothers is gearing up to launch their
streaming service right so it seemed
like it would make a ton of sense
do you like let this be your [ __ ]
flagship it's Sandman let this be that
the introduction to the world of the
things we can do on the streaming
service but Warner Brothers just laid
out 500 million dollars to get JJ and
bad robot signed to a deal they just
wait what he gets all that all that well
I mean the company will get it but it's
that they wrote a check to bad robot
saying would you please move your
offices over here I wish I was gonna say
I wish I had initials for a name but I
betcha it's a lot more than that isn't
it boy
probably talent and [ __ ] like that
nobility Jesus that's a lot of that's a
lot of money they just sorry how long is
that for by the way the deal I mean
probably between five and seven years
with options to renew but like that's
that's the arms race that TV is in right
now is get these giant mega producers
they just signed Greg Berlanti Stu like
a 10-year deal that's worth three
hundred million dollars chuckle Laurie's
deal is about to expire and they're
gonna want to resize him as well they're
about to spend a billion dollars on
literally three people and when they've
hit the salary cap and they've hit the
salary cap and they were like listen we
need to actually make some money before
we keep spending money and so the idea
that they could then go to Netflix and
say listen this was gonna cost you two
hundred million dollars to make this
show great penny asked that money you
need a little maybe a little income
because we're in the red that's the
theory so instead of like trying to earn
off of the show using it as a loss
leader or a hook for the new app to like
let's [ __ ] earn a book or two all
this Netflix will pay through the nose
that's awesome [ __ ] you want to talk
about like a worthy follow-up to Game of
Thrones man and I don't mean like it's
the same [ __ ] it's not
but in terms of taking like a beloved
fantasy literary project because that's
what the Sandman I've used graphic
literature but like there's a lot of
words in those books taking that to a
new medium and introducing people to
like concepts that a bunch of people
didn't know but the world of June
general didn't know just think about how
[ __ ] like blown away you were the
first time you were reading like you
know the story where he meets his sister
and then it turns out she's [ __ ] deaf
yeah and spoilers and like you know it's
like you're like death is a [ __ ] eat
like an emo goth girl of course this
makes [ __ ] sense
somebody's gonna get introduced to that
concept for the first time and I talked
about like when I had the heart attack
you know I thought about [ __ ] Sandman
when I was laying on the table and [ __ ]
thinking about dying
cuz you know I didn't get shitty I
wasn't like man [ __ ] why am I having
this heart attack it's unfair because I
just thought about that issue of Sandman
with him hanging out with his sister
she's death and he just goes from place
to place with her as she's delivering
people over from Landel living to the
land of the dead and stuff like that and
you know it's a full array of everybody
including like a baby is one of them and
[ __ ] like that but she comes calm across
this one older guy who's just like I
know who you are [ __ ] and he's like this
is it this is what I got my whole life
and [ __ ] he's unhappy with everything
he's like I did all that and what do I
get
and did def says like you get what
everybody gets you get all you got you
got what everybody gets you you got a
life
I thought about that when I was on the
table and I was like I oh [ __ ] like
that's I can't [ __ ] I got a life man
and granted it wasn't as long as I want
it to be but there were no guarantees
and I got a life and it worked out so
sayonara and [ __ ] so the fact that I
stuck around and I live and I get to see
The Sandman series I might get to see
that moment [ __ ] portrayed
so that's nothing but good news and the
fact that Neil's still involved you know
what I'm saying not that he's watching
from a distance going I hope they get it
right he's been involved with TV now
episodic and as much as Good Omens which
went very [ __ ] great
so he's how beautiful that a Creator who
created that [ __ ] is gonna still be
there when it makes the transition to
the biggest canvas of all time yeah I
mean there is there sort of like Stanley
jr. about it is that he's now getting to
watch all of the things that he did
before come to fruition in the best
possible versions of the my god you're
right that's such a brilliant parallel
and the thing that tickles me that warms
me so much is that this show will be on
the air whatever two three years from
now but it will have the Vertigo banner
on it will it for sure I mean it would I
bet sure it's not gonna be DC blackly if
there's one [ __ ] thing Neal will put
his hands down and be like you know what
we're doing it this way like that'd be
amazing I wonder if Karen Berger lines
up like as a producer or something like
that I mean she was the editor of all
those [ __ ] but she was what glorious
[ __ ] age we live in man where they're
doing the sand man not just doing it but
doing it insanely properly with him
involved there's gonna be no curveballs
again and how lovely for him if he looks
back at his work and all at all like it
like some creators and goes like huh you
know yours Ani but I would have done
that a little differently he gets to do
it himself and update it and be like no
I made that decision yes mine it's
[ __ ] awesome and that's the best
entertainment news I heard of the week
speaking of comic books first off though
before we go further yeah and we had
this discussion in the [ __ ] alley so
I'm gonna have it but like it's it's not
we had a quasi version of it but I'm
gonna do it here would you want to work
on that show I'll give you my answer and
okay and we both know each other's
answers because we just did it then the
show had to begin so we didn't get to
finish I was like oh my god [ __ ] I
said who would wanna write on that show
and he [ __ ] raised his hand and I
said what are you [ __ ] kidding me
Neil is gonna write every episode cuz he
[ __ ] broke every episode already man
if I'm him I'm like I did this [ __ ]
already let me just [ __ ] change it
like the date on the front page of the
scrip and here we go we're ready to go
dialogues dialogue and [ __ ] like that
like I wouldn't I couldn't see myself
adding anything to the proceedings as a
writer and then I thought like ooh maybe
I could direct and I'm like who the [ __ ]
am i kid and that shit's so visionary
and it was done in the 90s and I still
haven't caught up so I'll never [ __ ]
be a director on that [ __ ] and I would
never offer anything to it worthwhile as
a writer so in my head I'm like just
like with the Marvel movies I might
click fan mode like there's nothing
predatory about me where I'm like I want
to work on that the shark goes to work
or anything like that like I'll admit it
when they said Batwoman ammos I got this
is the closest I'll ever get to Gotham
City like and I already work in the
Berlanti verse maybe that'll work out
you know and she'll like that but
generally speaking I don't see [ __ ] and
go oh I should be involved I'm very easy
to click into fan mode and just be like
I can't wait to see that [ __ ] even
though I work in the same business I
don't need to work on any [ __ ] thing
there's a lot of [ __ ] I like to [ __ ]
see that has definitely [ __ ] one of
them you would work on it in a [ __ ]
heartbeat what an intimidating writers
room that would be what do you why do
you why why do you say that part of it
is because Sandman was the book that
made me want to be a writer I need all
right like I read it in high school look
out of high school when you're like I
don't we might be a [ __ ] architect
I can't draw maybe I'll be a little
advertising I don't like math like I
kind of might want to be a filmmaker but
I'm not sure but reading that book which
was so much about writing it was so much
about story were so much about the
possibilities of what story could be and
could do mm-hmm
that it was so in love with that and the
world had Neil built for himself let him
tell every kind of story he possibly
ever could have wanted to tell like I
want to tell Shakespeare I'm doing
Shakespeare I want to tell the story
about his African dream god I'm going to
do that I went a little story about
Lucifer I'm going to do that one tell a
story about a one guy like [ __ ] death
and dream have a bet over letting one
guy live forever and then they check in
with him every hundred years to see what
happens to him I forgot about that story
that was so
it's glorious and just this book could
do everything and if it's possible to be
able to make something that lets you
tell every story you've ever wanted to
tell I want to try that and so that book
very much nudged me in the direction of
maybe writing is your thing maybe the
freedom of writing is your thing maybe
the the the you can imagine everything
on the page and it is to a certain
degree not your responsibility to
execute it you just have to imagine it
and and there was something about that
that that changed my life in a very real
way and the fact that they're 22 pages
long and an average episode of TV is 60
minutes long like you have nothing but
room for invention within those stories
that you love maybe I would treat it too
reverently like I wouldn't want to hear
I'm working on I'm working on two
projects right now one is one that me
and Mark have talked about and [ __ ]
which obviously is not [ __ ] Sandman
but something else which we haven't
announced yet we're not at liberty now
so then there's this other thing I'm
working on as well which is a
reinvention of something and I it's
[ __ ] tough because I'm really reverent
toward the source material and what you
know the the network or whatever is
looking for is you know no we want your
version and I'm like but don't you
understand my version is the version
that you guys got like I'm not I'm not
gonna bring much new to this [ __ ]
table and [ __ ]
and I find that I have to work really
hard to get over the reverence for the
material to include new material I feel
[ __ ] dirty I felt that way as well
when I did it I adapted Flesch one years
ago the book wo and Fletch won and I
included new material and I felt really
[ __ ] dirty about it because I'm like
you got no business putting a new [ __ ]
but you you'd feel okay about throwing
new [ __ ] into sand man yeah I mean it's
it's I remember reading there's this
amazing book that screenwriter William
Goldman wrote who did all the
President's Men
and Butch Cassidy bride but Cassidy he
talks about adaptation and his his
perspective on it and he said I read if
I'm offered a book to adapt I read it
twice and then I never pick it up again
and then I tell my version of that story
to somebody else and that's the story
that I write because I'm remembering the
stuff that I love I'm remembering the
bits of it that really moved me and my
brain starts to connect the dots of
those things in ways that are somewhat
unique to me but are still retaining the
spirit of what the initial book was
that's [ __ ] clever man that's really
good because all we're trying to do is
get our audience excited about a story
we want to tell and the first person to
be excited is you and what makes you
excited is what you're gonna want to
tell somebody else and so being able to
do that with salmon would be a [ __ ]
dream to be able to sit there and say we
have 75 issues of glory and wonder which
of these are exciting me what which of
these moments do I love and how can I
help amplify those moments with other
moments that it will be unique to a new
viewer because I don't and I think it's
the reason why Neil doesn't want to
write it again is that I've read those
books
I know those stories he wrote those
stories he my guess is doesn't want to
write them again he wants the new stuff
like play in this world I built you a
world I gave you some fences I gave you
some guideposts I gave you a couple of
[ __ ] jungle gyms to climb on but
here's the world man tell some stories
and there is nothing more exciting to me
than being able to play in a world that
I love and do some new [ __ ] in it I'm
[ __ ] hey man well if you guys are
watching hire him he wants to [ __ ] him
play
you'd be an asset man you'd be here far
more imaginative than I am my [ __ ] would
be like put Jay Mewes in it what else we
got man that's fantastic news for all of
us but especially for Neil nothing good
for David and [ __ ] good for Alan
O'Shay good for [ __ ] Netflix but
[ __ ] fantastic for Neil
speaking of comic books a weird thing
happened today apparently I saw this
which is the most amazing [ __ ] baller
comic book flex I've ever seen issue 193
of The Walking Dead is the last issue of
The Walking Dead
now yeah those were like so what they
didn't [ __ ] tell anybody that it was
gonna be the last issue in fact I'll go
one further they solicited for future
issues and even had fake covers done so
that people wouldn't even [ __ ]
suspect that the end was near there was
no whiff of it in the air and [ __ ] and
finally just today like all of the
hoopla that we usually get when a giant
thing like that would look commemorative
issue and giant blowout and and view
which means for the comic book industry
huge orders as well right like if they
had a now it's like bless you know 193
is there 193 193 is gonna be the last
issue bless you that issue probably
could have sold 250 five hundred
thousand books mags is the final finale
but as he said baller n flex he didn't
tell anybody until tomorrow's new book
there somewhere today's new book
tomorrow tomorrow so he said it he
announced it today Robert Kirkman
creator of the book the writer of the
book of the Charlie Adlard
as well tony moore was one of the
original deaerators as well way back in
the beginning but Robert Kirkman has
been captaining the ship and stuff and
Roberts just such a [ __ ] light in
this world the really [ __ ] good dude
so and and funny and good-natured right
he's in Jay and Silent Bob reboot he
came out and did a [ __ ] part with us
and stuff very funny in the movie as
well so Robert announced like the book
is ending tomorrow and here's why we did
it this way he's like I hate the
part of the TV show when I know there's
only a few minutes left they're getting
into the day new ma and the thing that I
loved the most is coming to an end and I
hate that part in the movie where I've
just figured out oh [ __ ] they're
wrapping things up and we only got a few
more minutes left to that I hate that
feeling in a comic book when they tell
you the comic books coming to an end and
so every word every panel becomes like
oh [ __ ] this is almost we're almost
there and he goes and I just didn't want
to do that for anybody so instead he's
gone just like the spirit of this book
where you never knew which character was
gonna [ __ ] get killed next and it
always kept you on your toes we wanted
the ending of the book to be the same
way and there's the way he wanted it for
a long [ __ ] time man
and he was on my set [ __ ] just a few
months ago and she had and I was just
like when you end in that book he goes
no time soon because that smart
[ __ ] is like if I tell him
everyone will [ __ ] know what a
[ __ ] great move that was he killed
spoilers he kills Rick Grimes in 192
the last issue and so for him you know
the quote was like Shane's death and
Rick's death with a book marks the book
ends of this story I kill Shane an issue
one I'm killing Ricky an issue 192 and
193 is like a coda like here's kind of
just what happens to the world after
what happens to the world that Rick
helped build and then that's it he's
like I we're not coming back to it like
I'm not like I'm done but the TV show
will go on for as long as they want it
to go on there's a new spin-off about
like kids in college you don't know
about the zombie outbreak he's gonna be
a third show that's on the air you know
Andrew Lincoln is coming back to do like
TV movies or major maybe actual movie
Walking Dead's not going away it's not
going away but the book that story is
done that's pretty phenomenal that his
he runs one of the skyrim Skybound
Skybound his comic label and stuff like
that it behooves the guy who runs a
company to you know [ __ ] make as much
money as you can and [ __ ] but he
answered to the storyteller instead of
the the businessman that I I applaud him
like that's pretty [ __ ] awesome
and good for him ending and on his terms
the exact way he wanted to and whatnot
and he's got no end of stories in them
so that's [ __ ] phenomenal so yeah
tomorrow is your is the issue hits now
that everybody knows this like if you're
looking for it you just want a souvenir
[ __ ] good luck like hurry up oh go
[ __ ] him fast cuz everyone knows now not
because of us because it's way way out
there in the mirror yeah
were you a gremlins fan as a kid I this
says mark and silver do you mean mark
barnard n' as your silver marker oh you
arcsine and silver not me right
I wasn't at the movie [ __ ] you man I I
[Applause]
was very instrumental in making the
movie happen for y'all and [ __ ] I got to
go see it over the weekend knowing that
I had to shoot Impractical Jokers today
so I wasn't gonna be able to make it and
stuff so they were the folks that screen
acts were lovely enough to set up a
weekend screening where I saw it and it
was and again we're gonna talk about it
a little bit man but anyway where are we
what what is that it's a prince a keen
pup that's for me to keep oh you're
getting all the personalized [ __ ] man -
mark mark sign this Kevin [ __ ] off dude
I got I got three things here okay
were you a gremlins fan as a kid am i
signing the shirt oh that's my jesus
[ __ ] christ
[Applause]
what did you do at the screaming I
wasn't at man
let's just say my jaw is tired got a
buddy this is like [ __ ] mum my wife
gets mad when I take the kid out to eat
cheese like you guys are bonding without
me
[ __ ] bonding down my back fair
enough
alright so gremlins will you a fan of
course oh yeah man [ __ ] don't feed him
after midnight don't get them wet and
[ __ ] don't don't make a sequel past two
cuz they never did and it's such an easy
concept like why didn't they just keep
[ __ ] going and how come nobody's
[ __ ] redone it yet
yes woods Appetit
well it's about time there's like a
little later actually not too late I'll
take it but this should have happened a
while ago they are doing an animated
series what yes that's not what I
dreamed about two seconds ago I'm sorry
I'll go tell they're doing a cartoon
they're doing a cartoon for the Warner
Brothers streaming app maybe this is
what they spent all the money on we
could have Sandman but I said we're
doing a cartoon Mogwai show which is
exactly what they're doing
it's the origins of the Mogwai it's when
the the old dude who runs the Curiosity
Shop first meets gizmo in like 1938 or
something like that I mean I could get
you know what I would get behind a
version of the show where you know we
saw the one guy get the mug why but like
it was a shop and presumably he's been
there for a long time you just do it
like it's an anthology where everybody
gets gizmo one way everybody takes a
turn on gizmo sounds dirtier than I
meant it but but that way you follow
many stories how we just follow the one
story like someone else adopts gizmo
that's the pilot though like somebody
[ __ ] gizmo no it's look he may have the
ears for it but [ __ ] no it's it's the
must be live pigs episode of [ __ ]
gizmo show oh for [ __ ] America black
mirror yeah I guess that's how you'd
started [ __ ]
alright so cartoon gremlins cartoon
I mean I'll watch I'm look I'm getting
that app regardless so I'll definitely
check it out but I thought they were
gonna do another gremlins movie why not
another gremlins movie a thing I don't
know man so easy to [ __ ] do it really
is but I mean not for me or you but like
somebody with money in the and you know
the you like an IP Warner Brothers owns
that [ __ ] in in a world where we're
getting like a hundred million dollar
Dark Crystal puppet show yeah you you
might have thought that uh that gremlins
would be on the table yeah but uh but no
or maybe that's like that's what the
cartoons for stupid we want to see if
anyone's interested or but I'm who
wouldn't be interested in that it's
great concept man and plus like just
read it like the top into nostalgia of
like remember gremlins
remember when you like [ __ ] in the
[ __ ] 80s look at this [ __ ] like it
works over and over again so I pay to
see that especially because it's not
like now man like they're puppets they
were puppets then they better be [ __ ]
puppets now I probably be CG though
right I don't know if I'd be down for
that man makes you think dark crystals
not mix they said the [ __ ] Jew dude I
met over at in England that worked on
Dark Crystal one of the puppeteers said
that they did tests of CG characters
mixed with puppets and they were like
[ __ ] it let's just do all puppets and
they were like it's more expensive and
they were like [ __ ] it let's just do all
puppets so no mixture they want
straight-up puppets they took over a
[ __ ] giant soundstage and built that
set and I had to build it up because
everybody's working through the ass up
here and [ __ ] like that
so they spent much [ __ ] money man so
there's a way to do it look like if
Netflix did give [ __ ] gremlins you'd
probably get your hands off it yeah you
get puppets again hands and asses baby
alright what else you go uh let's see
Salma Hayek is a negotiation is to join
the Eternals Oh who else is in that
there's Camacho Madden Richard man
chimera Icarus Icarus dickarus
right and Kumail Nanjiani so for now her
wait wait and Angelina Jolie right
was rumored to be in it I'm sure madness
sign on for sure I love some I mean I
worked with the salmon of question many
years ago she's always so [ __ ] sweet
she she I just saw her in a movie what
did i watch the hummingbird project did
you see this now it's with Lex Luthor
from the Justice League movies Jesse
Eisenberg and then it was with the
[ __ ] vampire from True Blood the sexy
vampire we'd all [ __ ] Alexander
Skarsgard oh but they made him look like
me who's balding and chopping and [ __ ]
like that
so usually I know I was but it would've
been much cheaper they also got Salma
Hayek who has what I can only describe
to keep it on point here as Reed
Richards like hair she's got like dark
hair with like streak of gray throat
going through it which looks [ __ ]
stunning I was like holy [ __ ] that looks
I wish my hair looked like that her
being in a Marvel movie
I'm all for its wonderful actress and
[ __ ] she seems to be having like a
[ __ ] second act to a big career like
she you know her career never went
anywhere but suddenly people are like
hey she's really [ __ ] good samus on
the Somme Assange has begun I'm good man
that's awesome that's one person I get
next time I see her I'll be like tell me
about the eternal should be like no I
signed an NDA
[ __ ] that I made you an angel and Dogma
you owe me I call people like that all
the time
you obey Henry Cavill yeah Superman
Superman he is he's trading his cape for
a pipe for a pipe for Sherlock Holmes
oh yes yes why do I know this maybe we
talked about this on Babylon I think we
did we talked about on Babylon talk
about this is very cool they are making
a film called
Enola Holmes about like Sherlock's
younger sister I believe which
apparently is a series of why a books or
something yeah but yeah so he's playing
if I didn't Sherlock Holmes he's gonna
play Sherlock Holmes to his younger
sister Mycroft is also a character of
course
Brown was playing in NOLA yeah that's
cool right yeah so it's kind of like you
know like young Sherlock Holmes but with
the girl like Nancy Drew
oh yeah but but set and you know
Sherlock Holmes Ian times when does that
take place what year turn to the century
turn this he was like 18 may be
something very Ripper I still remember
the hounds of the Baskervilles but
that's about it it would be nice to hear
merely Bobby Brown not have to do an
American accent because I've never
actually heard her on screen and not do
that what do you mean every me not
American no she's British
that girl's British British oh no wonder
they cast her she's so convenient that's
awesome man I had no idea she's British
I don't think I ever heard her speak
I've seen like I almost said I've seen
her on Leno and that's how old I am I
feel her the Tonight Show you talk to
the [ __ ] circuit and she's charming
and British alright so she's gonna be a
no Nola's that you know yeah and all the
homes you know the homes I'm in that
family's not good with names I'm just
gonna say and I think that's good
casting though Henry Cavill as Sherlock
Holmes because he's so [ __ ] charming
and never gets to be charming that's
true
and I feel like you know in in limited
dosages the charm goes a long way if
he's like a tertiary character in that
he just swans in solves the things swans
out maybe gets kidnapped and and always
got to save him otherwise some other bad
[ __ ] happens down for that I'm so down
for it I would imagine there's a lot of
like you know she she's helping him
solve this or solving the mystery and
[ __ ] you know people a good job
Holmes and he's like she you know thanks
wink and you know [ __ ] star wipe and
out that was the 70s version alright so
is that the end of that that's the end
of that what else um Michael Chabon
are you familiar with his work yeah
Cavalier enclosure and clay
he's got a Pulitzer Prize for Literature
he's shiny as [ __ ] and and he is the new
showrunner for the Star Trek Picard
right on yeah that's classy super
classic that's cool and I
because nothing old ever gets to stay
old I am so down for a [ __ ] Picard TV
show yeah I think it's a cool idea but
it's nice to hear that that guy thinks
it's cool enough idea that he's involved
that's a certain pedigree right thing it
doesn't do a ton of TV but he's doing
starting now was he a big Trekkie
anybody no I guess he must have to be on
some level I think so I think so I've
never heard him talk about it but he was
I remember the announcement that he was
in the writers room hmm
like a year ago it had been working on
this forever but now he got promoted
from within which is always nice and and
yeah I can't [ __ ] wait for that show
yeah man another thing to watch what app
is that on that I apparently have to buy
see CBS all access oh I already bought
that I never watch it but I bought it
when it started tract disease Star Trek
in the beginning and I watched first
three and then like got busy and stuff
it was good but but I still pay for it
[ __ ] all right well I'm ready now you
got a thing and the last bit is just
more like a look at all these
[ __ ] who were going to Comic
Con this year what do you mean you got a
list of people going to comic-con watch
man we'll be at Comic Con they're gonna
do a panel they're gonna do a panel
they're gonna do like an environment
thing and like there's a lot of
off-campus activations this year as
there always are that's the word for now
activation activations where they build
a thing that you go walk through a thing
there's a VR thing well there's costume
dudes running around thing so yeah
Watchmen is gonna be there there's gonna
be some kind of Game of Thrones panel
there yeah the final game of Thrones
panel this is their big bow and where
they say goodbye and apparently
everybody throws rotten vegetables Adam
and [ __ ] you [ __ ] it up James that's
right Shane bunch of bells swing you're
gonna be going on no I'm sure they'll be
given a hero's exit yeah
the Russo brothers are going yeah I saw
that man I shot some video with them for
IMDB earlier in the week we did the pre
shoot for of course I'll be at San Diego
this year for the fourth year in a row
on the IMD boat behind Hall H
interviewing people and stuff like that
so as a pre
I a pre IMD boat thing we shot a bunch
of videos like the five things to see a
comic-con and then I did an interview
with the Russo brothers where it was
awesome I got to like really gush
hardcore I'd done it once to Anthony but
I hadn't done it to Joe and [ __ ] as I
was doing it to Joe Anthony was smiling
in that way of like oh he did this to me
like [ __ ] and Joe was on the spot
because it was like a lot of intense
[ __ ] fandom and [ __ ] and like and all
leading back to my dad where I'm like
you understand man those movies bring my
dad back to me do you understand like
he's movie shouldn't work I know how the
sausage is made but they're so [ __ ]
good that you bring my dad back to life
and he's like all right man I got it
that's thanks holy [ __ ] it's just a
[ __ ] superhero movie I'm like no it's
not so they're lovely [ __ ] people
they're gonna be on the boat as well at
one point yeah they're done with their
Marvel movies dun dun dun they've got
their thing was apke acabou Agbo with
Markus and McFeely what Marcus McFeely
who also be down there doing it their
own Hall H panel talking about
everything those dudes give good [ __ ]
conversation if you've listened to the
episode of fat man I'm Batman we did the
home show and also the one they did when
they were here yeah Marc isn't mcfeely
or fun they're so great but you have to
be with names like that Markus and
McFeely how are they depressing yeah I
guess it could be that too but now are
you what are you doing down there I'll
be on the IMD boat and then I've I'm a
guest this year of Comic Con for the
50th anniversary they actually invited
me as a guest which is really sweet
that's happened I think like twice once
or twice before yeah really nice so I'll
be there in a more official capacity
than I normally and rather than the
carpetbagging capacity I normally go in
attend Comic Con and I'm actually
invited this time around so I'll be on
the boat
I'll be doing a little one or two things
inside I am doing a Hall H panel where
Jay and I will be bringing the first
trailer for Jay and Silent Bob reboot to
debut right down there
which I've seen and [ __ ] absolutely
love I'm not gonna say the trailer is
better than the movie but it might be
it's just shorter it tells you like it
doesn't spoil anything but it'sit's
really [ __ ] good so we're gonna show
that and also there's a you know the
third act of our movie takes place and
an event called the I think most people
know this because I put an Instagram but
if you don't want to know anything about
Jay and Silent Bob reboot including at
home
close your ears I'll give you three
seconds one two three that was more than
three seconds the third act of the movie
takes place in an event called chronic
Caan which is based it's based on
comic-con of course but it's a homegrown
fan fest that has grown into a pop
culture festival that was predicated on
fans of the Bluntman and chronic movie
from Jay and Silent Bob strike back in
that movie they were making a movie
called Bluntman and chronic that Jay and
Silent Bob want to stop in the reality
of our movie that movie like was
Lebowski popular and and just says
Lebowski had Lebowski Fest like the
chronic con rose up around this dopey
movie which like had its hardcore fan
base but then it slowly unfolded into a
pop culture festival so even the logo of
chronicon looks like the comic-con logo
so much so that we had to show it to him
be like don't sue and they were very
nice about like go ahead so while we're
there in a Hall H after we show him the
trailer we're gonna show them our Hall H
scene from the movie so it's gonna be
really [ __ ] meta of them watching a
version of them watching [ __ ] them
it's gonna be kind of mine [ __ ] are
you sure they were cool with it
because they did invite you down to the
convention like here we saw that
[ __ ] you doing know you should come
this year you really should come this ya
don't have words with you I'd know
loading docks
it's like Goodfellas like just go down
there it's right over there all H is
right there I'm like I gotta go Jimmy
yeah just stand on the [ __ ] plastic
it's right
so that's me man what are you doing down
there I'm not working which is super
nice John justhe's fan this will be the
second year that I'm not a journalist at
Comic Con and that is my favorite Comic
Con I will be supporting Colonel Varro
which is having its big sort of premiere
diner Comic Con they're doing a
screening on one of the nights and
there's gonna be a giant [ __ ]
activation huh
Amazon is spending all the prime money
mm-hmm to make I think something that's
supposed to be like the Victorian
England street that is Cannavaro oshit
and then I will be announcing a comic
book project that I'm doing down there
that I can't talk about what it is
because I would be blowing the
announcement and lots of people would be
mad at me
oh yeah it's gonna be a good comment so
you guys I'm sure to do and there'll be
some announcements coming out yes we
will come back after the con on the 23rd
of July and do an immediately post con
Batman Beyond yes right afterwards the
next time we all gather is when July
July 23rd July 23rd after con okay we
done with the news we're done with the
news that's all the news give it up for
Markie did the news okay so did
everybody get to go see spider-man far
from home today for those who know you
haven't um it's gonna get we're gonna
spoil the [ __ ] out of it right here okay
yeah it's good seeing you
for those who haven't seen it at home we
are gonna spoil the [ __ ] out of [ __ ]
spider-man far from home so you've been
warned spoilers spoilers spoilers we
made sure that everybody here tonight
with the exception of some would see the
movies that we could talk about it last
episode or the episode before I guess
maybe
yeah the episode before we've wimzie
about like oh maybe we will get a
theatre and take everybody else maybe
we'll do it for TX style and our good
friend Brett Deacon who always hooks us
up with 40 X tickets that
give away in the QA and whatnot he said
a man the good folks of 40 X and screen
X said they'll they'll have the
screening for you they'll get you the
theater they'll even buy popcorn and
[ __ ] and I was like Jesus man so they
were really [ __ ] sweet about doing
that that's how you all got to go see
the movie for free I had talked about
yes I had I had talked about like oh
maybe I'll pay for it and I never had to
and that's Hollywood so but the good
folks who are responsible for the free
screening you had for DX and and also
you saw it in screen X tonight you're
gonna get to talk to it real quick we're
gonna sit here and chitchat with the man
who bought you all [ __ ] movie tickets
today give it up for Paul Kim ladies and
gentlemen now Paul you're the VP over it
for DX screen X and screen X is your
baby
exactly yeah you put it together you
were like this is what I think this
would be a dope I tried to yeah with the
team but definitely yes all right so
explain for those of everyone in the
room they saw it they get it for those
at home who have not what did we what
did we all see so imagine if you're in a
movie theater and you're watching a
screen on the center you know just the
screen right but for certain portions of
the film the walls kind of light up and
they become screens themselves so you
know you become completely surrounded in
this spectacular moment that you're
watching so if in spider-man if he's
swinging through the cities for example
all of a sudden you feel like you're
swinging with them and and that's the
whole concept is that we wanted to make
sure that the audience gets a little bit
something more and then just watching
the film it feels like you're really
part of the film and so it was just a
simple concept that we came up with that
turned out to work really well why not
what inspired that was it like what what
in your childhood did you stumble upon
it was like you know what I'm gonna do
in like 20 years this yeah you know what
make this movie better or of it I
thought but that's exactly what it is
right it's just really I mean we all
love films we all love watch
action films spider-man films moral
films and in this case specifically it
was just more of it that we wanted to
show and you know whether its motion
chairs like we do in 40 X or whether
it's actual visuals that you get more of
on screen X it's really just more about
feeling or having the audience feel like
they're immersed in the film and that's
the great thing about film is that
you're watching the story and we don't
touch the story the story is still on
the center screen it's just really how
can we add to this element a little bit
more in we thought well there's all this
unused space why not just use it to show
more visuals so where does that what
does that information come from because
it's not like I've been into theaters
that's kind of like we're just gonna put
some [ __ ] neon on the wall and so
it'll be blue when there's blue on the
screen will be red here like but this is
legit actual visual information like you
watch information travel from the middle
screen that you're watching over to the
left and right screen and that's not
what the filmmakers composed for but
you're able to make it seem like it's
all part of the story right and so we do
work with the filmmakers and you know
there's a misconception that we actually
take the DCP we blow it up we stretch it
out but we don't do that at all we just
leave the the actual film as it is and
so what we do is we work with the
filmmakers the good folks at Marvel and
Sony they helped us out and they allowed
us to take you know control of some of
those assets those VFX assets and some
may be unused footage and we start
creating and building out all of that
extra footage that you guys got to see
today
[ __ ] dynamic man it was really
awesome
I enjoyed the [ __ ] out of it I was
actually surprised that it requires two
more monitors like two more projectors
in order but it makes sense because
you're projecting a whole screen worth
of image and stuff but I loved what I
saw in Spider Man you saw black panther
snow black panther in him and that was
incredibly immersive I would imagine
what Conda absolutely like when the
moment that I remember is when you're
like in the scene in the movie spoilers
you go to a Conda right and so you were
like the Royal Talent fighter and and
it's that moment where it pushes through
the force fields of just the canopy that
we're in Wakanda a continent
yes that and but it's then suddenly what
Kahn is just [ __ ] everywhere and it's
amazing just nothing but spires and
buildings and and the a built out
version the city you can't see in the
regular ngon screen X version of it and
it's it's captivating like that was oh
[ __ ] there's the possibility here like
and there's there's and it's not just
environmental like it's experiential in
a way that's super nice and you guys get
to pick the [ __ ] that you like they
don't say hey why don't you do this
you're like this is how we can interact
with the movie without interrupting the
movie well I mean we give our input and
the filmmakers also have a say so it's
really a collaborative effort and we
feel like okay well condo is a perfect
example that works and so we put it in
we all agree then we work with the VFX
vendors and we start building it out and
and that's what you get it's [ __ ]
fantastic where can people see where
they saw it here in town we took
everybody to Koreatown is where the
theater is and it was what theater there
cgv cinemas I saw it over and then the
little testing facility which not open
to the public where can folks at home
work and others go see some screen here
in LA we have one at the Irvine Spectrum
we have one at the CG B theaters in
Koreatown we have them throughout the
nation there are about 25 sites right
now so it's fairly new but we're
expanding mostly at Regal sites so if
you go to the Regal website you'll be
able to see where the local screen acts
theaters are I saw it that way I could
batch for these cats you all like it and
in
can you can you tell us what's next on
the runway screen right now we have Jay
and Silent Bob reboot far more
information on the sides just a bunch of
cast and crew on the side looking at
their watches we have a slate of titles
that's upcoming almost one a month right
now but I unfortunately I can't say as
soon as I have the word we're gonna just
start putting it up on our website so
Paul come on just between us goils maybe
wait maybe once the the tapes for
nothing in the back alley
thank you for hosting us and given us a
screen and man give it up all right
thank you guys
Rob thank you thank you thank you and
also going back even further every time
we give out tickets man thanks for that
but that's that's what comes that's
Brett deacon right there in the back
give it up for the great Brad diggin
ladies gentlemen whose are these do you
want me to pull it out I believe they're
for us those are yours this is my book
oh my bad never pull out dude yeah yeah
okay Edward Davis I thank you for this
comic this is called immortal arrow he
gave mark and I comics since the thanks
ed for continuously encouraging creators
this wouldn't exist without you man
that's so [ __ ] sweet thank you and
their folks are making a documentary
called keV heads which is an indie
documentary exploring the fandom
surrounding writer director Kevin Smith
and the artists he has inspired like the
cat's we just heard from how sweet
filmmakers hope to gather footage from
fans and events around the world
focusing on the most personal inspiring
stories as well as hearing the
perspectives of some of Smith's
colleagues and collaborators that would
include you grab a sticker and follow
them via the links if you have something
to share share it with them at keV heads
dock on Twitter and Facebook so tonight
before you get out of here if you
grab a sticker grab a keV head sticker
man get involved you want to be involved
in that movie that's so creative okay
let's [ __ ] talk about what we came
here to talk about I Spider Man far from
home before we dived here let's do it
the right way how many people enjoyed
this movie put your hands together I
don't want to poison the well at all but
like that seemed to be a real
crowd-pleaser but how many people did
not enjoy the movie [ __ ] a man
[ __ ] a that's pretty fantastic
like what Wow could you imagine like in
this world like think about divided this
[ __ ] world is man you can't say [ __ ]
without people being like [ __ ] out and
the only thing that could bring us
together is we all liked Spider Man it's
something we can build on oh my god
okay this movie I thought was absolute
[ __ ] joy as I referenced before like
I gauge the movies you know some people
like you [ __ ] love everything it's
absolute [ __ ] a lot of [ __ ] I don't
love and you'll never hear about them
but you will hear about the [ __ ] I love
all [ __ ] day long and I'll talk about
[ __ ] spider-man far from home all day
long because there's absolutely movie I
love reminds me of the movies that I
went to see when I was a kid and movies
were still [ __ ] magic and stuff
reminds me of Empire Strikes Back
Raiders of the Lost Ark young Indiana
Jones not young Indiana Jones young
Sherlock Holmes I didn't enjoy young
Indiana Jones but it's not real big part
of my childhood it reminds me of all the
movies that captured my imagination when
I went to the movies and walked out
speaking about it breathlessly ebullient
Lee dissecting it wanting more instantly
so incredibly gratifying and satisfying
felt like a sequel but not in a bad way
by any stretch of the imagination but
did feel like hey man the story's moving
forward and these the characters we all
know and love and you know it doesn't
necessarily build on the exact events of
of homecoming but like you know it's
although familiar kids and [ __ ] like
that and then also this time around like
it's a high school like just as last one
was a high school movie this is a high
school movie where they go on the class
trip and it's more of a high school
romance it's way more romance going on
this movie than the last one totally
welcome because you're in very romantic
cities all around the globe they
introduce a villain you never imagined
you would have seen in a movie when you
were a kid or even as a [ __ ]
grown-ass adult and pull off the
single-best
incarnation of that character ever
committed to any [ __ ] media and I say
that is a guy who wrote Mysterio at one
point and they they somehow managed to
sequel eyes a movie we just saw a few
months ago by being endgame 1.5 and
tying deeply into a storyline that we're
all [ __ ] invested in and giving us
this great sense of closure in a great
sense of the future and a great sense of
like the boy will become king
they reached in pulled your heart out
and [ __ ] squeezed it and hugged it
and stuff shoved it back into your chest
as you know Peter Parker who's never had
a dad you know and then lose his Uncle
Ben at one point and stuff and now his
lost Tony Stark always loses his father
figure has to find a way to go on and
become a man all of it executed
brilliantly all of it [ __ ] perfect
and [ __ ] like that and as you come into
a close at the end of the movie you're
like this is amazing so obviously we'll
do the next year of high school with
Peter Parker and [ __ ] and that'll be a
senior year and so we'll do an entire
like high school kind of triptych and
this is great and then all of a sudden
the mid-credits sequence happened and
suddenly i don't know how to describe
this movie in any other way but an
amazing movie was stolen by the
mid-credits sequence movie which was
what two minutes at best but managed to
make you almost forget the events which
were breathtaking man [ __ ] Jake
Gyllenhaal so [ __ ] it's nuts man
that's a sailor's a married straight man
and again the [ __ ] bringing in mr.
Owen tying him into Tony and Stark was
[ __ ] fantastic all of it was glorious
and they start the credits you know like
[ __ ] hey this is the toy story of
Marvel movies they cannot get it wrong
and [ __ ] like that
and then just when you thought it was
[ __ ] safe to be like let's enjoy this
mid credit sequence it's about slavery
suddenly they're like walk in the face
for [ __ ] oh my god how awesome and
think about it like John Watts is that
the director yeah and the writers
anybody know their names I can't
remember but it wasn't the Jawas Daly it
wasn't the guys who do they're two
different dudes they did a great job
those dudes what an amazing job they did
all they had to do is set the table and
[ __ ] run like they don't have to tell
that story yet they got a couple [ __ ]
ears so they're like everyone knows he's
spider-man buy and [ __ ] ran oh my god
I've never been more [ __ ] ebullient
at the end of a flick and more angry
that the flick ended and that we
wouldn't see a sequel for a red-hot
[ __ ] minute but now more thrilled for
the [ __ ] future any time I'm ever
depressed and like you know what I'm old
and maybe I'll die one day I will live
to see what these [ __ ] are gonna do
next there's no there's no status quo in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe they won't
[ __ ] let it happen just when you get
company and you're like I get it and
[ __ ] they're like [ __ ] even with
[ __ ] ant-man and the wasp just when
you hear come for you like oh he's got a
little kid and game like [ __ ] she's
20 you know like [ __ ] and with Peter
Parker you just felt like right on man
like now they got their high school
movies down and he's gonna get to do the
final high school movie and [ __ ] and
then they'll move them over to college
cuz that's what they did in the comic
books and they're just like [ __ ] you man
here's the big dick of we're gonna smack
Spidey around next time everyone's gonna
[ __ ] know who he is that romance that
they just built is gonna be blown up
into the wind who knows what happens to
[ __ ] Aunt May we could speculate for
years which is what we're gonna have to
can do because the movie sequel won't be
here for quite some time and I doubt
they'll even touch it
I mean where else could they possibly
touch the storyline it's not like
there's another Avengers movie coming up
so it's gonna be two years minimum maybe
three before we [ __ ] get to see how
bad they [ __ ] up Peter Parker's life but
I for one am happy they did and I love
that character and I loved everything
they did with the character in those two
movies but with that breathtaking
storytelling move I was just like
gentlemen
take it it's yours I I thought it was
fantastic you I concur
let's talk about that before we touch
anything let's talk about that the great
fanservice moment just when you're like
[ __ ] this whole movies great fanservice
I can't believe they [ __ ] now
Mysterio and Tiedemann Tony isn't all
[ __ ] great [ __ ] Edith even dead I'm
the hero
brilliant [ __ ] high all this [ __ ] is
fantastic and then they bring in this
mid credit sequence which not only like
turns the [ __ ] table on on the story
but they give us [ __ ] JK Simmons as J
jonah Jameson again man that that is
such plan service so the moment I saw
his face I was like you classy sons of
[ __ ] that's so [ __ ] smart but then
even more so what I thought was
fantastic was I didn't think about this
in the last movie they didn't [ __ ]
introduce J Jonah or the Daily Bugle or
anything like that but you know I
assumed as they go on of course sooner
or later Peters gonna get a job being a
photographer and [ __ ] in the paper
and never thinking newspaper that don't
[ __ ] that world is gone and [ __ ] so
they can't do it the reinvention of the
Daily Bugle as was it Alex Jones
Infowars
and Jay jonah Jameson as a conspiracy
theorist is [ __ ] its dotnet is that
what it is Daily Bugle dotnet is [ __ ]
fantastic I was I thought that was so
incredibly [ __ ] clever not just to be
like hey remember the guy you loved in
the
he's the guy in this one cuz you said
you wanted that and guess what [ __ ] you
you got what you wanted [ __ ] but then on
top of that the reinvention of that
character is far more exciting than any
previous incarnation cinematically of
that character cuz this is [ __ ] gross
you know what I'm saying it's one thing
to have Jay jonah Jameson be the guy at
the newspaper who's like who's
spider-man meanwhile here's the sports
this is a guy whose whole [ __ ] life
now is gonna be about [ __ ]
superheroes and particularly about Peter
Parker I thought that moment that little
payoff with Mysterio [ __ ] him in the
end was so Mysterio like so [ __ ]
perfect and [ __ ] like that and as they
set it up where he's going
spider-man is and it crackles out and
you're like oh thank god and then comes
back he's like Peter Parker oh I forgot
loved it you know what it honestly goes
up there with I am your father in terms
of a [ __ ] twist but they waited till
after the [ __ ] credits man that's
[ __ ] confidence and they were like
look let's tell our story our story
happily ends here and [ __ ] and [ __ ] you
oh I [ __ ] love that but yes seeing JK
Simmons come back apparently he's not
gonna be [ __ ] busy doing James Gordon
anymore so see him come back to the role
that he [ __ ] made famous is fantastic
and seeing it in that carnot incarnation
equally fantastic now uninterrupted what
did you think I concur
there there I I agree with you a hundred
percent like I there's I'm I cannot find
a way to be shitty about this movie oh
it's [ __ ] it's like a child's
Christmas it's just so perfect it really
is a full it's these little moments like
and I only thought of it just now you're
talking about it you know tell Tony and
Uncle Ben as Peters father figures did
you catch the suitcase yeah I saw that
in the trailer yeah Uncle Ben it's Uncle
Ben's suitcase yeah at the end of the
movie it's gone like it explodes like He
shed the baggage of that both Tony do
you think they knew that metaphor
salutely because they put on this
[ __ ] luggage that's good doesn't have
that luggage with him he doesn't have to
carry that weight of being that guy
that's whenever I can't [ __ ] write
first sand as [ __ ] sand man
I can't even decipher a simple [ __ ] like
that that's good and I and I love the
fact that even though going into that
movie you know that mysterio is probably
the bad guy
what yes they bury it so quickly like
they answer the questions you have
before you ask them which is who's that
forget Mysterio we know I'm from an
alternate universe where like this is
what happened to me oh [ __ ] I ok
alternate universe Mysterio maybe he's
good on that side like you literally I
just gave you props for being a smart
storyteller and [ __ ] you're like maybe
he is good it's one of those like they
they defuse the bomb before you know
it's gonna go off not your eye is not on
that ball anymore and they give you
elementals to worry about like [ __ ]
about that me look I love the movie but
I was just like all right let me see the
turn show me to hustle cuz I knew I knew
there was something coming what I didn't
know it was the sting and that's what
[ __ ] delighted me because I knew of
course look he's [ __ ] his [ __ ]
Quentin Beck Mysterio there's no way he
doesn't [ __ ] turn out to be the bad
guy and [ __ ] they did make this girl's
good but there were other villains and
Captain Marvel without an obvious
villain like the elementals I shouldn't
count one not there you knew it was
gonna be [ __ ] Mysterio so that being
said how they made it Mysterio team
Mysterio
yes was such a brilliant reinvention of
the idea how the tech behind him
they didn't make him like you know in
the comics he's a special-effects wizard
this is his [ __ ] close as you get
it's getting pretty close to more
convincing than just doing a
special-effects wizard but I thought was
fantastic that he was wearing a mocap
suit in the third act not just a [ __ ]
mocap suit but a mocap suit with a
bubble head so that even when he wasn't
Mysterio he was [ __ ] Mysterio and he
allowed spider-man to punch him and
crack that [ __ ] bubble dome like all
the [ __ ] that you loved from comics was
present in one level or another
including Mysterio mind [ __ ]
spider-man yeah that sequence so great
is [ __ ] I can't wait to be home own that
on home video wake up in the morning get
really high and just watch that part
over and over again oh it's fantastic
and they did all the [ __ ] you want them
to do like they use his head as a snow
globe and [ __ ] like that
it was fantastic I love that yeah I mean
I love the moment where you get the big
Mysterio reveal that it's it's only
second in the Marvel Universe to the
Mandarin reveal for me which is a lot of
the reasons why this feels a little bit
like Iron Man 3 just it I felt like and
I don't know if they're going for that
on purpose but I did feel like oh
there's a familiarity here but I liked
that because they tie Peter and Tony
together yes so well so I'll I don't
feel like oh we've done this before I
mean look on some level like we've done
all the stories before you know they're
superheroes like superhero stories have
a kind of archetype to him and stuff but
I was I was I was happy with what they
did with this whereas was Mandarin I was
like oh I would have actually liked to
see the Mandarin like I liked their idea
but I kind of you know as a traditional
comic book fan I was like where's the
Mandarin the real Mandarin and here I
feel like they did give us the real
Quentin back the real Mysterio while
going above and beyond and giving this
is this whole other world we're like oh
that's clever that makes sense this
would do it I think also like Iron Man 3
it's very much about trauma right it's
very much about post endgame like the
loss of Tony Snow
and they are never subtle about Tony is
everywhere that Peter goes there's some
mural and a wall there's some giant
billboard that's got his name on it
there's stories that so much reading on
the plane that he's being haunted by the
guy who he can't ever hope to live up to
and and and in in Iron Man 3 it's very
much he's haunted by New York he's
haunted by like I died and I couldn't
stop everything like I laid myself in
the line for it it's gonna happen again
I'm driven by it and I can't run away
from it so he runs away from me you know
and and Peter to a certain degree is
running away from having to wrestle with
being a superhero by going on a school
trip I just wanted to kiss this girl by
by having this list of things that he
thinks that he needs to do in order to
be a real boy when the truth is that he
just needs to and I think happy will
even says it to him it's like you know
we don't need you to be the next Iron
Man we need you to be spider-man man we
need to be you who you are who's the
best version of you like there's never
gonna be another Tony and even if there
was Tony made this [ __ ] up all along
anyway like the Tony you have in your
head is not the Tony who was so you can
abandon that idea of perfection and just
be the you that you're supposed to be
and that happy scene on the plane is a
[ __ ] tearjerker yeah that's where I
cried I cried when Peter starts taking
apart the tech he's like you don't need
this and he's doing what Tony didn't
they put his hand in the way that Tony
put his in in it and then they cut to
happy and happy clocked it as well and I
was already crying at that point but I
was like oh my god but then I was like
happy didn't see [ __ ] Ironman do any
of that [ __ ] man
I watched Ironman a zillion times happy
was never there going I see what you're
up to but I got the spirit of the thing
I was [ __ ] all for it that made me
[ __ ] well up that was beautiful yeah
anyone that was cute though as awesome
where he's just like I'll take care of
the music and he's like I love Led
Zeppelin but that was sweet and really
touching for Favreau to be in that scene
Favreau established ac/dc and the sound
of Iron Man and stuff so I think
honestly like watching him run around in
this one and whatnot I'm just happy for
him because he without him you know get
the Marvel Universe as we know it today
he builds a really strong spine with
[ __ ] Iron Man and whatnot and then
didn't wind up getting to do the vendors
which he probably should have done him
it but now has come back in you know
look he's [ __ ] not hard up for work
obviously lying things about to make
every dollar that was ever printed in
the United States and [ __ ] but he also
gets to come back and be in the Marvel
Universe like you know last time we did
a spider-man movie like they paid a [ __ ]
ton a movie money to get Robert Downey
jr. in it this time around they didn't
pay nearly as much to get Jon Favreau in
it but they got same bang for the buck
to some respect because the closest
thing to Tony Stark in the movies
besides Pepper Potts would be happy and
the closest thing the Iron Man was John
Favreau
he took it [ __ ] from the page to the
screen and [ __ ] so all of that scene hit
me right in the [ __ ] fields again and
it's Tom Holland is so good at this this
kids great yeah not only does he Best
Buy really yeah best moment because he
actually looks like he's 16 yeah first
like oh he's a child
i buy that who can probably also drink i
buy that too but but Kerry's a movie
because he's like II look even when he's
spider-man now like they have him lifted
up there's eyepieces so you're seeing
him so he's more present as the as the
hero but this was more Peter Parker yeah
the spectacular spider-man it was more
Peter Parker then Spiderman was a and
not saying that in a bad way at all he's
just charming enough to carry the movie
without the [ __ ] suit like that's how
[ __ ] good he is again like Iron Man 3
which was very much about Robert now
yeah that [ __ ] suit anymore and I
don't think this kid's like I don't want
to be in the soup but they're just like
this kids good let's [ __ ] let's not
trap him in the suit let's let him do
some [ __ ] as himself and the bit that
got me not just on the happy on the
plane stuff but it's at the very tail
end when they're on the Tower Bridge and
it's over and like Mary Jane like runs
over to him and you just see like broken
[ __ ] spider-man
who's so happy to see this girl who he
doesn't have to lie to anymore who can
actually [ __ ] kiss I was just oh
Peter gets what he wants
yeah finally gets what he wants cuz
they're about to [ __ ] him in five
minutes
which you go ahead Peter kissed a girl
happily ever after and end credits yes
but no it's just it you're right it's a
romance more than it's a comedy and then
I remember feeling that about halfway
through it's not as funny as the first
one but it's not the same movies the
first although Ned provides all the
requisite laughs Ned's little romance
with Betty Betty that like begins on the
plane and ends when they land it was
kind of adorable particularly with like
it's great movie set up she a classic
movie set up [ __ ] that's gonna work
today it's gonna work 30 years from now
of him being like let's be European
bachelors and then [ __ ] landing and
being like I'm in a relationship and
like that moment when like he you know
Nick Fury enters the movie and he's like
I remember when I first fell in love he
was just happened like [ __ ] two days
ago yeah that kids really funny Jacob
what is his name got a lot really
[ __ ] funny great addition their cast
is wonderful zendaya really charming and
they gave her a lot more to do this time
and like she got to be not just the you
know chick who's like I love the black
dahlia because of the murder but also
like I I knew you were pewter they they
gave her she was like I was a 69 percent
sure that you were spider-man
they let her be smart as opposed to you
know every other incarnation and whatnot
it's it she did a Gwen derful job
Sam Jackson was the most Sam Jackson as
Nick Fury Sam there was a there's a
bunch of the time in the movie work one
could say that it felt like Sam Jackson
was playing Sam Jackson and then at the
end of the movie you're like Sam Jackson
was playing Sam Jackson so do you think
he knew in advance I think so I think
you knew because I feel like it's
because it seems like a button that
could have come up with afterwards as
well what is it
right the scroll is revering Captain
Marvel so like that part in the script
is like he'd he knows that he's not just
playing Nick Fury at that point yes and
he says call cavalry says get your name
out of your mouth well that could have
worked for Sam Jackson's with the Kree
with the scrolls oh that's [ __ ] dope
I feel like it's a bit like you know we
talked about in the alley it's the Chris
Evans playing Loki playing Captain
America right so it's like the most
version of Captain America was like look
how patriotic I am I feel like the most
Sam Jackson is what a scroll would
pretend singe Nick furious right right
that was a sweet that's the second post
go the end credits sequences the reveal
spoilers of course that uh Nick Fury
hasn't been Nick Fury the whole [ __ ]
movie neither has agent Maria hill they
there it's Talos to tell us and what was
Julie taking their place the whole
[ __ ] movie which then had me
scratching my head going wait a second
how long is Nick Fury not been Nick Fury
but I guess we're an all in agreement
that Nick Fury was Nick Fury Nick Fury
got snapped away at the end of infinity
war yes then Nick Fury was in the at the
funeral at the end of end game and then
presumably left earth with Captain
Marvel that checks out spacecations
but I think what they're setting us up
for is we're going right we're going out
into the galaxy Nick Fury is lost
interest in earth and all the threats
are from above maybe agent of shits Nick
Fury cosmic agent of shield or something
what is it sword oh my god is that what
they're talking about doing speculatin
whoo [ __ ] that's nice
that's I mean even that was a nice thing
in the post-credits sequence where
you're like holy [ __ ] like they're
showing you what phase four is gonna be
we're leaving [ __ ] earth we're going
to the star ISM and I love that phase
four is not I mean it
it's cosmic in that you see the Nick
Fury Stover the end but the one that
hits the most it's intimate yes here's
Peters life just torn asunder it's not
look at this new stone it's not we got a
[ __ ] hammer in the ground it's not
it's not throwing to some larger story
it's throwing to oh this poor [ __ ]
kid I love that let's talk about
Gyllenhaal I crushed it man did a really
great job is bittersweet because he was
one of the names that was thrown around
years ago for spider-man himself so it's
nice that he's in a spider-man movie and
I'll be honest with you I thought they
gave him something better to do than be
spider-man yeah what what what a complex
wonderful original yet familiar villain
to introduce instantly top [ __ ] 3
Marvel Cinematic Universe villains for
me you up there over these top three
who's who are your top three Thanos
number one kill monger number one oh wow
that's good you know what yeah [ __ ]
he made a lot of sense yeah I think I
think Loki Loki is - I don't know if we
can count Wilson Fisk
I mean Fanus is 3 and then you get to
like vulture and Red Skull we go a long
ways before we hit Bulger before Red
Skull I don't know man I would still I
might throw him up there I think love's
really good the backstory was so like oh
[ __ ] they're bitter about stark and
then tying it into barf
was [ __ ] fantastic like just a
throwaway moment and like in civil war
where you didn't really think much of it
other than like oh we get it it's
important to the story because later on
we're gonna find out that Tony's parents
were killed by the Winter Soldier blah
blah blah but instead you know the
writers of this movie were like we're
gonna borrow this and we're gonna retcon
my man into the background and where
he's like he called it barf like yeah
like it's it's ingenious in a way that I
love I don't think it's quite as as
emotional as vultures yes you know which
is like I this was my job I supposed to
do this thing I provide for my family
and the government came and took away my
livelihood
and so I gotta get what I can when I can
while I can and I got to do it for these
people that I love like that that to me
is a little bit I mean it's a lot more
investing then I'm angry at Tony Stark
who took what was mine like it's revenge
for Mysterio
whereas vultures lucky if you just left
me alone everybody wins
yeah yeah I get that I still do so much
fun I like that I it's to me feels like
classic movie trope to be like I'm a dad
and this is why I became that feels a
classic comic book trope as well the
Peter Billingsley returns he was the guy
who played the dude in iron man they
showed the flashback where [ __ ] Jeff
Bridges yelled at him like Tony Stark
one of these rocks that that's Peter
Billingsley who was a little boy and
Christmas story he he was yeah he was
real tight with Favreau and and the
other one Vince Vaughn and [ __ ] like
that so he I think he directed a movie
with Vince Vaughn and Favreau in it I
figured the vacation movie but he's been
in that circle and he was in [ __ ]
Iron Man cause him and Favreau friends
so for them to grab that character and
bring him in like that's incredible
fanservice like that's like oh a few
people remember this guy once they
showed that clip everybody remember that
guy yeah I mean I loved that that from a
from a story mechanics perspective
mm-hmm making Quentin Beck a previous
Tony Stark employee makes him Tony Stark
ultimately for Peter like that's that's
Peters in is like my father figure the
guy who was the closest that I've ever
met to being actual Tony Stark he's
[ __ ] brilliant and he knows science
he knows all this stuff he's ultimately
like tony proxy that guy to be evil for
that guy to turn on Peter for that got a
no Peter secret for that guy who Peter
trusted enough to make him the next Tony
Stark like there's you would have had to
put that in whatever villain you choose
is he's got to be directly wired into
who Tony was the the beard and
everything they just kind of made him
look
Tony ish not like on point but close
enough particularly when he puts on the
e to the glasses at one point and Peter
looks at him and he's satisfied he sees
[ __ ] Tony wearing the glasses and
that's when they do the sting turn I
thought it was great
making it a team and making it a team
effort and making it a scam and [ __ ]
like that I was glad honestly that it
wasn't like there is a multiverse and
I've come from it I thought it was great
that he was just like people you have to
make it more ridiculous for them to
believe it now like you know and I love
that things were like we need an
Avengers level threat like like in that
world it all exists I love that they
don't call it the snap we call it the
snap because we saw the movie but they
call it the blip because they didn't see
the movie that we saw that when everyone
left they blip that was incredibly
charming support is adorable it really
is and it proves they have all the money
because it opens with a throwaway
[ __ ] like just like in a kids video
of Whitney Houston's I will always love
you one of the most expensive [ __ ]
songs in the world man but it was pitch
perfect and she made a lot of [ __ ]
sense that video was adorable thought
alike stolen clipart and [ __ ] like that
really good time the there's some [ __ ]
that was in the trailer like him going
to get his passport and that didn't pop
up in the movie or him talking to the
cops where he's like I gotta do your job
and like oh [ __ ] but I didn't miss him
in the movie but it was at the end I was
like I didn't remember saying that [ __ ]
what was the running time anybody would
know it's a to 208 209 [ __ ] Chucky
bit of time I guess something had to go
although everything after endgame is oh
this is fine it's like a diet movie it
really was yeah it was wonderful man
they're doing the right things over
there like no complaints whatsoever but
once again you know the the the villains
all the tech everything they had to
fight was built by Tony Stark like the
bad guy in all these movies is Tony
[ __ ] Stark man it's always him
cleaning up his messes or somebody else
cleaning up its [ __ ]
as much as we love Ironman he really
[ __ ] [ __ ] up and whatnot it's like no
nobody knows there's just a thousand
satellites in the air there's still six
dark industries that have weapons of
mass destruction
yeah okay can we get the keys to that
it'd be awesome if you didn't look like
a sixteen year old do it it was cool
though there was a bit of Charlie and
the Chocolate Factory to it and as much
as like he gave the golden ticket to him
yeah I loved it all right so rather than
dive into Q&A what we're gonna do is
open it up to you guys cuz you all saw
the movie as well so I'm sure you got
some original thoughts about it and
whatnot let's keep it like tight so we
can do a bunch of people how about we do
[ __ ] ten
we'll hear your thoughts on the movie
cuz you just serve the [ __ ] out of arts
and stuff so instead of Q&A we'll keep
it spider themed if everyone's cool with
that JC picked somebody who wants to
talk about spider-man give us your
thoughts and feelings man JC he'll pick
you there's hands going up over there
his hands going up over here we got Oh
what we got a taker jump on over here to
the lit spot what's your name young
soldier AJ AJ well give it up for AJ
what'd you think of the movie man give
us your review I mean amazing spider-man
yeah I just wanted to point out
something how they got around villain
splaining and like in the you know
meeting scene explained yeah how they
you know how they were having the
celebration and they were like you did
this you did you did great you did great
everybody did great and you did this
this this and this and this was my plan
this was my plan this was your plan a
lot of exposition at scene and
entertaining to notice it until
completely after the movie so they got
away with villains planning basically
the entire plot of the villains plan
which I thought was pretty smart see if
you can do it in a classy entertaining
way man a trope still [ __ ] works good
observation you got thoughts on the Hat
it's it's a bit like the Raiders of the
Lost Ark scene where he doesn't talks
like the army guys and they just for
like five minutes leave just drop anchor
and explain [ __ ] to Indiana Jones yeah
who then explains [ __ ] back to them but
because it's done in a fashion that
we're on board with and like Indy gets
to assert his knowledge Indy gets to
give you the sense of oh no I am
qualified for this I understand what
this is what are these this is a power
of God or some [ __ ]
whatever like you can do it like you
said if you do it well and if you do it
entertaining you can gloss over these
giant just wad folds of exposition and
you don't care like champagne and hand
March it across a bar yeah that dude
could have told you like the Gettysburg
Address and he'd have been happy with it
that was my favorite writing part of the
movie I think ya know it's super solid
and really smart cuz you can have to do
it yeah so let's do it so that in a way
that you kind of dig it I like those
little tricks where you know they get
around some get around a trope by clever
writing yeah that's my favorite thing is
what it is man like look I'm it's it's
nice to be genius at something I'm sure
I have no idea but I'll take being
clever any [ __ ] day man cuz clever
will get you around [ __ ] [ __ ] clever
all good to get people just impressed
like long enough which is all you need
in a movie you don't need them to think
you're brilliant like [ __ ] you just
do ha that's clever until they get home
and be like wait a second that sucked
you know what I'm saying so clever can
get you through and that was a clever
observation give it up for EM lazy Joe
hey Jay you let us off who we got next
JC what's your name young camper that's
C I'm gonna give it up a bad day you're
at this Betsy right on what you think
what you thinking spider-man or what you
guys make an observation you got
something you want to say spider-man
when they announced a third a third
reboot after amazing spider-man I was
like we could have just stopped I was
with you at one point and then they
started making on like uber right and
then I watched on Holland I was like got
it so it's like Robert Downey jr. is now
Iron Man forever I got it okay cool and
it fit better and now I'm actually
interested in getting the comics and
actually finding out the whole thing as
good will take converts more of us less
of them welcome I mean so for me it was
actually just a very visually
entertaining movie and it had a great
like continuous storyline through the
last three I mean obviously I've seen
all of them in theaters so I saw I
didn't even watch amazing spider-man 1
win saw amazing spider-man 2 and I was
like well it was a good movie that's
fine I still don't like spider-man
that's fine after the Tom Holland first
movie I was like oh actually a good
character development crazy in the right
hand and the director who we didn't blow
nearly enough John Wat yeah [ __ ] this
guy's fantastic seriously man I like for
me the mark of a good director is I
never once sit there during a movie and
be like I would have done this or I
would do this different everything makes
me go like holy [ __ ] like oh I'm
captured with wonder yet again so this
this kids doing it man the last one was
an absolute ball of joy and [ __ ] this
one was a ball of joy and it's not just
like ah the good warm feelings of
spider-man he's a well made [ __ ]
movies well told stories like that
[ __ ] sequence you know I know there
were lots of it's not just the directors
lots of visual effects artists involved
in a sequence like that but the mine
[ __ ] Mysterio mine [ __ ] sequence that's
filmmaking
that's fantastic the spider-sense
sequence or the Peter tingle if you will
which I know you were like it wasn't
funny as the last one but Peter tingle
was fantastic and they kept it [ __ ]
running and [ __ ] like that and the first
time they said it I was like oh
Peter tingle and said her spider sense
but then I thought about was like Peter
tingle that's a dick joke like I was so
when they yes when they did the Peter
tingle sequence down the hallway which
was essentially him using a spider sense
to attack all the [ __ ] drones that
was that's fantastic filmmaking man like
that's really bad guys doing a great job
and the character stuff is wonderful he
took us on a tour of the world they
actually went and shot oversea
so yeah man John Watts doing a great
[ __ ] job look we all love Sam Raimi
an amazing spider-man - one of the
greatest spider-man Mother great
superhero movies ever made
see only spider-man soundtrack I've ever
bought come on man - not amazing
spider-man - spider-man - Sam Raimi's
spider-man - I think I said Raimi
spider-man - but maybe I don't know
we'll check the table regardless the one
with Doc Ock yeah wonderful superhero
movie top ten type superhero movie but I
feel like John Watts - up at bats at
spider-man is is hitting as strong as
[ __ ] Raimi did yeah so that's a
really great friend thank thank that guy
for making a spider-man we could all
[ __ ] get behind
well done man give it up thank you two
down eight to go if it's another one JC
thank you
hey hey well they won't give it up a
well Thanks what do you got first man
Spider thoughts so going back to the
conversation you guys is having how you
know the twist that Nick Fury is
actually scroll and actually on our way
over here my wife actually is one who
brought up so criticals to her so that's
a scene remember one day have a call
she's right there so she's she brought
to my attention was the fact that
remember how they kind of had the whole
protocol half happy calling um Nick Fury
and tell him that hey remember to
surfboard auto stuff but don't judge the
book by its cover and it kind of takes
it is interesting there in the end he
was actually Telus the whole time yeah
and remember and Captain Marvel the
whole time we're thinking oh this grows
bad oh they gonna do something bad watch
they go do something bad and then the
whole point were to reveal that is I oh
my god it makes perfect sense like when
a totem is like wow yeah that is and a
great used the character - so close -
Captain Marvel like Captain Marvel just
happened a minute ago and then suddenly
endgame happen and we're like yeah so
you know the scrolls were wonderful
characters in Captain Marvel but these
Marvel movies come so thick and fast
that you're on to the next [ __ ] thing
it was nice that they didn't wait too
long and [ __ ] put it into effect to
be like remember these cats and he said
meadow I was hot
yes recommend thoughts I that moment
bump me a tiny bit because like Happy's
giving code to a dude who shouldn't
understand the code right like if it's a
thing that they'd had worked out but he
could talk to fury obviously like cuz he
but he contacted fury and fury goes to
them yeah just it's a little wofully in
that moment where like ultimately
doesn't [ __ ] matter because Nick Fury
doesn't do anything in that moment that
requires saving of anyone and did you
say they didn't get the code oh so so
when happy was like you got the code he
was like yeah but he didn't really get
the code she said you did get the code
oh he sent Maria hill up at the rocket
launcher you should say he was gonna
stay there like you know do you want to
see how this whole thing goes down this
is why we have these discussions to
figure this [ __ ] out
yeah I'll tell you one thing you
mentioned surf board when they said surf
board in the movie I was like holy [ __ ]
The Herald of Galactus you know like
they're starting with the FF there's
coming but instead it was just you know
[ __ ] Sam Jackson on the beach for the
surfboard but yeah for one brief second
I was like oh my god it's [ __ ] it's
all happenin yes excellent observation
give it up for EM lazy thinking well
done give it up for her ladies and
gentlemen well done yeah nice job three
down seven to go give us another victim
there JC so many people what's your name
captain Brian Ryan everyone give it up
for Brian
you got an arc reactor in your hoody man
you're in the right place that's my
Starck reactor as a stark reactor so two
charming things in the movie like I
obviously loved it like everybody in
this room but the explanation of what
happened post blip or post snap and like
the whole band coming out of nowhere and
they're like the best basketball team
running into them that was really it was
such a cute and clever bit and it like
Tim when when end game came out people
were going like well what if you got
[ __ ] snapped back and you were in a
plane you just fought so there were all
those and you know these filmmakers must
have been like we know what happens when
you come back like because they showed
us right in the [ __ ] beginning the
band comes back and [ __ ] runs into
the basketball players yeah I loves
really the the Salvation Army
fundraising drive for like the new wave
of homeless yes disappeared for five
years and moved into their apartments my
favorite one was like that grandma load
there was a ghost in my house and
they're like oh my grandma I appeared
and my grandma thought it was a ghost in
the house and it's like oh my wife
thought I was cheating on her or that
was like I thought my wife snapped away
because she just left what's his name
for freaks and geeks the actor Martin
Starr was really funny and we also
didn't mention maybe someday be smooth
he had the line that made me [ __ ]
laugh out loud he goes what do you
think's happened he goes as a man of
science which is just the [ __ ] pause
between science and witches really
[ __ ] baby left as a man of science
witches my other favorite moment when he
facts it like dialed in the Peter tingle
and Quentin Beck was an illusion
and like I heard the bang and I thought
he caught the [ __ ] bullet I was like
oh my god how dope was it that they
literally let Quentin like Quentin Beck
was pretty shitty in the movie and was
constantly talking about now I have to
kill Peter and like would have shot him
in the [ __ ] head use like one last
illusion it was going to try to [ __ ]
kill him so like it justifies his death
like please let him be holding that
bullet yeah no I was just [ __ ] glad
that they pulled it like pulled it off i
I hadn't even seen that one coming I
thought I'm so [ __ ] stupid
that I thought the guy on the ground was
him and this is the end and [ __ ] and
that last little twist I was like oh
[ __ ] that's cool and then they twist it
even more in the mid credit sequence
when he's like spider-man who's Peter
Parker
I'm telling you man top [ __ ] three
villain for me that's great you think
he's gone twists and turns and also even
in if he's dead I do think he's dead
okay and even in death he's still
[ __ ] with Peter Parker and if they
make 20 of these movies you could circle
back to Mysterio yeah even if he's dead
somebody else can bring all that [ __ ]
tech back dude who just [ __ ] beat
Billingsley who pulls out that [ __ ] well
as the impression I got was Billingsley
as the guys responsible for all that
information being out there so maybe he
gets to come back as well his character
oh I loved it I love this farm we could
all talk about [ __ ] that I forgot give
it up for a mouse this is from you oh my
god this is from Brian look at this man
it's a it's for the legend for our
friend my mentor thank you that is all
the Marvel Cinematic Universe characters
under a picture of Stan so it's not just
heroes it's everyone from the Marvel
Cinematic Universe even the net you put
daredevil in there's yet give it up for
Brian man that's beautiful I'll put that
[ __ ] up in my house I'm alright what
else we got hey what's your name Chester
Chester give it up for Chester everybody
thoughts on spider-man far from home so
everybody was talking about the action
and everything and I thought that the
this does the sequence they had weird
happy and his aren't like everybody
seems to just pass over they're like
Peters like what are y'all doing like
drama happened to him the fact that you
brought up his him his loot him losing
his uncle suitcase if you look at May
she's still in a I don't know if I want
to go to a relationship but she don't
know she might still want to do
and it shows like progress and from
everything that I've ever seen I don't
think she's ever been in a relationship
so like this would be like I was first
for them to do that yeah I thought that
was kind of interesting that was cool
but I thought it was so like cold when
she was like Roman no I think it's more
a summer fling fling and he's like what
this is a long haul I bought a ring I
thought that was I thought that was
really cool I thought just it's small
but it's something that you don't see
and it was nice it was a nice runner
with like hinted at the trailer in the
trailer like hey there might be a happy
yet kind of thing and they played it
well and and what was the misdirect in
that scene where suddenly Peter was
sitting down and talking to him the
beginning like he's saying something
you've what is it yeah about there's
been enough lies and then it reveals
those two like it like movies got a
great sense of humor and they're set
pieces they're setups and payoffs are
really well done it's so somebody look
up the writers names it really goes into
more about Peters life than spider-man
it did it was definitely more Peter
Parker movie which is something thank
you for saying that because I wanted to
say something before that I forgot it's
proof positive that in the hands of like
strong storytellers you can take the
titular character spider-man leave the
spider behind tell a story about the man
and people will still be interested like
imagine if they did that with Bruce
Wayne they've never been able to do that
with Bruce Wayne maybe close with the
period with the Christopher Nolan stuff
and whatnot but still Batman is the more
interesting character we like the way it
looks the way he fights the way he's
well [ __ ] Lagoo but imagine if they
did a Batman movie like and maybe that's
the one that they're working on with
Robert Pattinson where Bruce Wayne was
as interesting as Peter Parker was in
this movie that I'd go on the adventure
more with Bruce Wayne than just [ __ ]
like get him in the suit I want to see
him be the bat yeah but you but you also
have that being at the spider-man game
was so good and it dealt more with
Peters life was like okay well people
like this yeah under the movie you know
saying so later he had something to base
it off of and I did
see a couple of similarities from the
game in the movie but my said that as
well he's taking the pictures when he's
swinging in the end like it's it's at
fun of it right it's the this should be
the most fun thing in the world and they
let him do it right before they [ __ ]
him yes
like they just every good - happy ending
he's swinging through the canyons and
you know taking pictures of himself
inside on spider-man and then credits
and then heard that spider-man's life he
doesn't have happiness long no and
that's that's what I was so delighted by
I was like they [ __ ] him and I was mad
but I was like but that's what they did
in the comics over and [ __ ] over
again and Jonah's supposed to be the one
[ __ ] yeah good great observations give
it up for him again cuz he's right like
so much of it is in the small moments
right somewhat to what makes both of
these spider-man movies work is he still
tiny things and it's rarely when he's
actually spider-man but when he wants to
be the best version of himself when he's
you know in the [ __ ] in the first one
in homecoming when he's in the car with
with what's-her-face with the vulture
and his daughter oniy turns around and
as that conversation you know spider-man
get up spider-man okay get up spider you
made me cry don't [ __ ] do that I love
that moment
get up spider-man his voice is cracking
[ __ ] that's [ __ ] awesome yeah there
was no get up spider-man moment in this
but it was more it wasn't get up
spider-man I've been physically beaten
it was get up spider-man be they be the
year of the Tony he was on the plane
with happy and he's crying and he thinks
he's lost and he gave the [ __ ]
glasses to the wrong guy and my friends
are in danger and he's just completely
bereft and then Happy's like nah man you
got this bereft on a private jet it's
the worst kind of sad there is I want to
shout out a little moment in the movie
that I thought it was quick and it was
[ __ ] you know part of something
larger but for a certain fanbase it had
to be everything during the Mysterio
mindfuck sequence when they show Iron
Man crawling out of the grave he looked
like oh he looked like a Marvel zombie
and I was like holy [ __ ] they touched on
Marvel Zombies as well this is [ __ ]
dope what do you got Chris Chris McKenna
and Eric summers
who did homecoming ant-man and the wasp
in Jumanji all right so they wrote they
wrote homecoming they worked on
homecoming but there were other writers
right they're credited as writers on
homecoming ant-man in the wasp and
Jumanji I mean I didn't see Jumanji by
like those other two movies Jim I don't
yeah the rock Jumanji the new one yeah
the new one yeah I saw the old one
charming they did community as well
there the writers came from community
that usually means you're right
I'm Lego Batman I [ __ ] love that too
he's great man it's so crazy because for
a long time in this business you always
saw the same [ __ ] names right in the
big movies over and over again literally
the same [ __ ] names and you know
sometimes it's great but like who wrote
all the spider-man's David Koepp or
something like that yeah like not
against guy there was a minute where
kept wrote [ __ ] every Jurassic Park
the spider-man movie and they were they
delivered so I'm not bitching about it
but at the same time it's I love it when
I look up and I'm like who are these
writers
where'd they [ __ ] come from and then
also and somebody's like oh they came
from community or some [ __ ] sitcom
like what like I I love seeing new names
up there and say yeah anyway what's your
name Jim Jim man thoughts on spider-man
for me I'm always a bit of an audiophile
so for me the soundtrack actually hit
pretty well I thought they went a lily a
little bit like guardians on trying to
hit like some eclectic music and like it
make it a little bit like a high school
yeah but for me actually them using back
in black actually was a really big one
for me just that being a big song for
ac/dc them emerging as a band again
after their lead singer had died and
then this being a big song after Tony
Stark
the band's that's really [ __ ] cool
well observe I love those audio
flashbacks like it gets done really well
in Star Trek beyond when because in the
first Star Trek movie when young [ __ ]
James Carter stealing his dad's Stingray
he's playing The Beastie Boys sabotage
on the radio yeah and then in [ __ ]
Star Trek beyond two movies later it's
we need some disruptive audio that can
blow up the blobby blue and fry up the
Skiz bang and it was like I got just a
thing and he's like [ __ ] at the helm
of this starship and just sabotage is
playing those guys on fire there's also
that thing in a I want to say it's
Terminator Salvation well yeah when I
when cuz when you first meet the movie
with the big wheel in it yes is the one
to make G you did yes you remember
anything about that movie here's what I
remember I remember that in Terminator 2
yeah young John Connors riding on his
motorcycle listening to Guns N'Roses
you'll be mine yeah yeah and then in
Salvation later on he's riding on a
motorcycle kind of by himself down the
pole hi Jax one of the one of the
terminators that's like a motorcycle
yeah and it's the he's full of some of
that music playing that you just made me
want to go watch that movie again well
done but but that idea that like the
music that you listen to as a young
person becomes the soundtrack of your
life going forward and it means
different things to you at different
times and so for Tony to have been all
about [ __ ] back in black or happy to
have been all about back in black for
them that to means something for for
[ __ ] Peter in a kind of off way it's
just delightful did they also was there
another Ramones track at the end of the
movie yeah yeah just like far as I'm
coming there was another Ramones track
and and that also lured me into this
false sense of like safety where I was
like Oh things are wrapping up and
they're gonna wrap up all of these
movies with a Ramones tune that's very
clever and stuff and I wonder what the
next one holy [ __ ]
nothing will ever be the same you know
minutes later even with the Whitney
Houston I mean they were kind of trying
to soothe you through it a little bit
but then they brought back the ac/dc and
you're like okay and we're back to can
expensive soundtrack man ones expensive
movie excellent observation give it up
them lazy on me okay have five or six
who's keeping count six so is this about
to be seven
here comes seven what's your name my
name is Krista Krista won't give it up
for Chris okay what didn't you like
I hated that it ended specially the
moment it did I was like why what didn't
I like about the movie disclaimer I
wasn't able to see the movie today
oh I'm honestly trying to think if there
was anything I didn't like about the
movie I would have I wish I was in it I
wish you were everything to you yeah but
other than that I got no complaints
about the move honestly I like you know
I don't know some people like you're a
[ __ ] shill for Marvel I wish they
don't pay [ __ ] but well I guess they
will on Howard the Duck right up until
then they haven't paid me [ __ ] but I
just love these [ __ ] movies man
that's the only reason I'm way into it
like I said I wasn't able to see it but
you know I hear everything you guys
loved about it so what like I said what
did you like the only thing that I
didn't like was I wanted Nick Fury to
have a little bit more to do with an
actual wait in the plot like right very
like if you pull him out of it
like you kind of don't really need him
he he propels he's like hey Peter you
got to go do this thing with this guy
and then after that he's got Bosley in
the movie when I always want more out of
[ __ ] McPhee that's a Charlie's Angels
reference yeah by the way did you see
the trailer I did what do you think yeah
like it either needs to be like [ __ ]
the original like McGee's Charlie's
Angels love those two movies it's like
Daffy in candy colors and super goofy
human cartoon yeah and it's in a super
fun way so where are they used to be
that kind of goofy or the action needs
to be like [ __ ] John wick you need to
be atomic blond you need to do something
special and from what I saw like it's oh
no they
oh the Kristen Stewart and like tan
girls kind of doing fighting
I can't tell any of them apart who's not
Kristen Stewart like it's just and
that's why he didn't like spider-man yes
I'm here for Elizabeth Banks I love like
pitch perfect and pitch perfect like to
specifically but this trailer didn't do
anything for me and I don't know if it's
the movies fault or the trailers fault I
think Kristen Stewart
I liked Kristen Stewart as though
because I think she can be funny and I
don't think she ever gets a chance
really to be funny and she's very kind
of serious and serious actress but on
SNL she's been funny I interviewed it
once in real life she was funny and
charming so I liked what I saw in the
trailer of her I'm like yeah there's a
[ __ ] great use of her yeah but anyway
back to spider-man that was that was it
the only thing I just wanted a little
bit more Nick Fury oh my wake to that
character but yeah I can honestly can't
think of a single [ __ ] thing that I
like I didn't like you have a suggestion
go ahead I wish you hadn't said that oh
my god what a great line number one for
those at home again here he said the
Peter and MJ relationship ship seems a
little half-baked and then over here
they said like most relationships and I
hope it wasn't the guy was like my wife
said something clever because you're
[ __ ] okay alright alright fair enough
that was my point in the alley we were
talking I said I felt like their
relationship was like a like suddenly
they're into each other in this movie
where I said at that suddenly she's into
him and I felt like like last time she
was like I don't know well no I said
what did I say I said I thought he was
into her and then mark was like no he
was in love with the vultures daughter
and I had [ __ ] forgotten that that MJ
was just a buddy and [ __ ] so then at
that point I'm like oh alright well they
both weren't like overly into and one
another but now they are in this movie
and I just took like well we had time
off the blip whatever the [ __ ] but I
would yeah I would agree
with you that it was suddenly like oh I
guess they're here in this part of the
relationship where they're kind of but
they are in high school and that's the
other thing you could like easily write
it off too like it's a high school movie
so it can be fast and awkward and weird
and wonderful
I didn't bump it into it so hardcore but
you're right if you have to what does it
call the pair split hairs that would be
something because I did kind of say
something earlier about like did were
they deeply romances throw it in there
for female demographic sorry so yeah I
sometimes I feel like with romance they
put it into sorry sometimes I feel like
with romance they just throw it in there
just say hey let's piece the women yes
and this did that didn't feel like it in
this case like I didn't feel like they
were like just throw some [ __ ]
romance in there for the women because I
did you feel there like this felt
honestly more like history where the
like peter has to fall for MJ sooner or
later that economics history and it felt
like by the end you're like oh we
realized why they [ __ ] move that
along because they're like in the next
movie they're gonna jeopardize that you
see I was okay with it because you're in
Peters perspective and your average high
school boy has no [ __ ] idea what
women are thinking they have no game at
all
they have no game and they have no clue
and they have no insight so if you're in
Peters if you're riding with Peter he
has no idea how she feels about him and
so the movie because you're in his POV
doesn't know how she feels about him
either until she declares it and the
only thing he knows is whenever she's
around he gets a Peter tingle that's why
she says low hanging fruit sorry
literally well he hasn't descended all
the way yet that was great observation
give it up for a lazy lover thank you
Jonathan I lose count so easily you
still hold that we got an excellent
point over here you still think that
that romance was better written than the
Hulk Natasha one second it absolutely
absolutely and so note so people on the
internet aren't like they don't like the
Romans I I did like the Romans I thought
it worked well but like you I was like
what I was [ __ ] fast that came out of
nowhere but to be fair they're so
[ __ ] charming you just go with it you
know and I'll buy the high school thing
too and as much as like everything when
you were younger was like oh my god this
is it the big moment and it happens out
of nowhere so I go with that what's your
name man hey I'm Frank Frank right give
it up for Frank everybody mark yes
fellow member of the Bronx just to the
previous point they kind of teased it at
the end of homecoming when she takes
over the the decathlon the academic
decathlon group she kind of kind of
lingers on Peter when he's like oh I
gotta go she does that thing so there
was a bit of setup at the tail end of
the last one yeah what about for him did
they set him up at all no no no he's
oblivious so the camera stays on her for
a bit Joseph so he never in in
homecoming had any MJ feelings no no no
I'm gonna next time so next time I
watched this I'm gonna go I might
actually go again tonight man
I might I'm gonna look at the with an
eye toward the relationship just to see
like how they get into it because I was
filling in the blanks of on my own I
guess with comics history or just
knowing all the movies or where it's
going or whatever the [ __ ] I put in
information that wasn't there maybe I'm
gonna watch it anyway so I just wanted
to kind of piggyback on the John Watts
observation and this is something MCU
like obviously with Kevin Feige kind of
running it and also yes before we
[ __ ] go a step [ __ ] further we've
blown everybody in regards to this movie
except the guy who really probably
deserves all the blowing from now until
the end of time the only Kevin that
matters in this world Kevin Feige
give it up once again man
everything the dudes involved with just
[ __ ] I love it you should I'm John
yeah I could be [ __ ] killed and
someone could be like Kevin Feige
planted I'd be like brilliant well I was
just going to say the reason why the MCU
works the way it works is that they
identify and and specifically Kevin
Feige I assume identifies the core of
each character and and no character like
even just like a tertiary character
escapes this kind of scrutiny they they
they identify what that character is
about where they're broken why and I
feel like John watts in these two
spider-man movies has done that better
than any of the directors for any of the
AMC excellent [ __ ] pol great line I
think like you understand why Mysterio
is is is pissed you with Stark all of
that but like even just the the callback
to Iron Man one where the guys like Tony
Stark built that in the cave I'm not
Sony start like every character gets
that and for something like spider-man I
mean that's the heart of it spider-man
is it's every spider-man stories about
Peter Parker it's not about the costume
or anything like that and it's about
broken people and and what they do to
keep going
the mystery also of what John watts is
doing with spider-man is that unlike
every other MCU director he never got to
tell an origin story ah yeah literally
he understands the character so much
that he conveys the character without
telling that's how the character got to
be that character and that's to a
certain degree because the buter Parker
story it much like the [ __ ] Bruce
Wayne story might as well be Old
Testament at this point we don't really
need to know again spider bite powers
great power comes great responsibility
we know we don't need it anymore
spider-man spider-man in 30 seconds by
Mark Barnard
you know like we don't we don't need
Batman cinema we don't need Clark Kents
anymore like we know that [ __ ] and so he
gets to come into it and just tell us a
story about this kid who's a high school
kid who doesn't fit in and his body's
doing some weird [ __ ] and there's a girl
that he likes and her dad hates him like
it just gets to be 18 excuse me
and then a teenage movie right that also
happens to have spider-man in it and
that's what makes it tick like an
understanding that Peter Parker was
always that character was always that
high school kid full of insecurities and
full of self-doubt and full of you know
the the the gathered array of problems
that descend on a sixteen-year-old kid
he just can also [ __ ] in the swing yeah
like that would be a weird dark twist
for the next one though like Peter's
uncovered so he's like [ __ ] it I'm just
gonna start swinging and yes Peter
enters the world of adult trading the
Tingler the Peter tickle hard work you
guys brought up Batman just previously
you know how they weren't doing it in
the movies except for the Bale kind of
but that's what Tom King has been doing
on Batman doing more Bruce Wayne than
Batman the in the comics this whole run
that they cut short I don't know why
they did that but whatever DC is gonna
DC sorry yeah man that's did he did Tom
King write the DA of the story about ace
the bat-hound that's such a [ __ ]
beautiful piece of work like absolutely
[ __ ] fantastic and he's doing a lot
of Batman stories that are more Bruce
than that yeah yeah I mean he's a
compelling character like I get it
believe me nobody loves Batman more than
me and that's in the name of the show
but at the same time it's like the guy
who decides to put on the suit like that
guy's a wreck like let's jump inside of
his head in a world where they're making
a [ __ ] series about Alfred the butler
man where they can make Alfred sexy at
this point where you know you're like
[ __ ] I'd [ __ ] Alfred and they're doing
it without a cape and a mask like they
can [ __ ] tell a Bruce Wayne's story I
think an adult Bruce Wayne I know
they've done that on Gotham for a couple
seasons young Bruce Wayne but to tell an
adult Bruce Wayne's story
that's equal and I'm not saying leave
Batman out but fifty-fifty in the movies
it's generally like 50/50 Batman and 50%
you know [ __ ] the villains the
villains are always more interesting but
who's more interesting than the guy
that's like I the only way I could deal
with trauma is to [ __ ] do this like
this is the only thing that helps and
this is this is how I sleep at night but
I don't sleep at night because I just go
around beating up [ __ ] muggers
because I never want same [ __ ] happen to
me as a kid happen to anybody else like
I've read about that guy alone right
there without him [ __ ] punching the
Scarecrow although I do like that don't
get me wrong I love violence in comics
because I'm so nonviolent in real life
and [ __ ] in such a total wuss I would
never get into a fight but I laughed
nervously during movies my wife hates it
like it's not nervous laughter but she
says it's nervous laughter when anyone
gets [ __ ] punched kicked out of
nowhere [ __ ] I'm like haha like I get
this [ __ ] really does it for me [ __ ]
so that part of the character I love a
guy who's just like my parents are dead
and then he beats the [ __ ] out of
everybody because he's mad about it that
was a great point give it up for him a
great observation two more to go ladies
and gentlemen jacy's I do love bad ass
off for the butler that trailer looks
[ __ ] good it's on epics
yeah Alfred and like that was another
show where you know I was like Alfred
really but [ __ ] it looks really good
would you like one lump or two hey man
what's your name hi Carlos what is it
Carlos
everyone give it up for Carlos I loved
it I thought that was great
I wanted to kind of touch on the same
point a little bit but more that Spider
Man has always been about identity and
though all of the films and all of the
comic books touch on that it's and all
of the superheroes really have an
identity crisis no one has that crisis
more than Peter Parker and in this film
they really do touch on that they they
the whole struggle with identity and
they give him his identity only to take
it away in the mid credit scene or put
it out in the world crate that was
released there is really nice man you're
absolutely right he's a great point just
when you're like right on man he knows
who the [ __ ] he is now
like nope you don't know [ __ ] yeah and
they do go out of their way at least
four or five times they're in the movie
to talk about how important his secret
identity is to him to talk about you got
to put the mask on before you go shake
those hands and get those autographs and
it's true do I need a different suit I
can't be [ __ ] spider-man in Europe
then they'll know my family them that
can't happen like it's good point yeah
he was very protective of very super
protective so that when you get to the
mid-credits scene you're you're loaded
you're amped for this is the most
important thing in the world to him is
keeping the people he loves safe and if
he gets found out they're in danger and
then he gets found out right because as
a filmmaker film lover and a filmmaker I
think that character arc is the most
important thing and that's exactly what
they do with with Tom Hollands Peter
Parker is here's your identity I'm
taking it away again here it is again
and and just that play is is really
really interesting for this character or
to me and who where do you think it goes
next what do you think they do in the
next one like cats out of the bag so
wait well okay but that's what I thought
I was like holy [ __ ] if Peters exposed
that means the road to miles begins
maybe well I think the also the sex oh
so all the villains are like we know who
the [ __ ] we know Peter Parker is
spider-man well I mean vulture knew that
already right well I think they could
also expand on what is it
Skol sleeper cells
holy [ __ ]
that's a line in the movies goal scroll
sweepers I don't think I can't even say
it scroll sleeper cell scroll sleeper
cells it's tough to say I mean the other
thing you could do is I don't know if
they're ever gonna reconstitute shield
but you know Peter Parker agent of
shield like protect my family I will do
whatever you need me to do just keep
[ __ ] you know absolutely witness
protection but and may suddenly seems
Jane and a tiny man like or Scarlet
Spider that's true oh my god maybe the
spider clone will come back the commies
in the end of it all they're just either
heap or refugio anybody they're gonna he
might just create a whole new persona
for himself as Peter Parker and as
spider-man you know Doctor Strange Tim
he better not man I like the fact that
they put stakes into the world you know
what I'm saying like we've seen a bunch
of movies now where Peter Parker's
secret identity is spider-man oh [ __ ]
and they gave us two in this new
iteration but now they're like look what
we like to do is show you something
you've never seen that you didn't know
that you desperately wanted another
thing is Tony Stark didn't care and that
was Peter to role model you know he his
identity was revealed he didn't care he
was exposed to do a thing we're like dr.
strange Peter goes to doctors Genesis is
it can you help me everybody knows who I
am I gotta I gotta make it so that
nobody knows who I am anymore and dr.
Saroyan's cast a spell and everybody
forgets him including Aunt May and
including Mary Jane including his best
friend and so now his greatest wish
becomes the curse of all the people that
I love do not know who I am anymore that
is such a good writing I came listening
to it
oh my god that'd be cool all right you
could totally play that story now that
gives you just gave it out there sorry
stop these are excellent [ __ ] points
give it up for a man well done Thank You
Carlos
Carlos our tenth victim sir what's your
name captain oh I had to wiggle my fat
ass out of that booth hi I'm Nicholas
and we'll give it up for Nicholas
Nicholas you gonna take us home what are
your observations on Spider Man far from
I absolutely love the movie the end of
it hit me in the nuts like Flash
Thompson got hit No yeah we didn't
really talk about him man was fantastic
okay and also a bittersweet ending one
is like [ __ ] Butler shows up yeah
mother's not here yeah I think he's
gonna be venom but whatever no no no
okay so my question is Quentin back you
don't think he's dead I think he's dead
I don't think he's dead you think they
left him alive because Peter Billingsley
said when he said just go full you know
full hologram on it just bring back the
whole thing right he says I don't know
how you're gonna pull this off I think
it kind of alluded to the fact that he
doesn't die in that sequence like he set
up like a triple inception so could
Lucian within an illusion within an
illusion I by that character that would
totally work didn't you just do a life
signs reading and how is it yeah didn't
she do the he did he was wearing the
glasses but he had just had on those
goggles before that it's true Peter
yanked him off his head so we don't know
what he setup in there and Quentin back
was pretty pretty adamant about making
sure those illusions stayed the way they
were so it's true so they could easily
pawn back and even if he's not dead with
the new iteration of Quentin bag what
villain would you guys like to see
reimagined and how would you do it hmm
great question not what we're doing but
we'll do it
I'm terrible at for madam sorry who
would be good you start your Roger uh I
wanna I want the Rhino I won the Rhino I
think I think if you pretend that the
Rhino is like let's say he's a burn
victim right and he needs an entire skin
graft on his body and so so [ __ ]
magic science and here's the skin they
could put on him but it's it's too thick
it's too hard it doesn't feel anything
it doesn't allow him to have a normal
life again and maybe he was a fireman
maybe was a [ __ ] wrestler cuz Stan
loved wrestlers and here's a man trapped
in skin that is in his that he can't
feel anything anymore and so the one
thing that he wants to do is find a way
to feel something and the only thing he
can feel any Mors rage and then maybe
there's a way to make the Rhino not
quite as jokey's around had been but
here's a bruiser who can't stand himself
who lashes out in the world and
spider-man has to find a way to do
spider-man things that was good
Kraven the hunter as a serial absolutely
Raven as a serial killer where you know
I've killed [ __ ] look at all these
animals but man is the greatest game and
so he's a serial killer that spider-man
has to pull down that's you know it's
not just I'm a big-game hunter looking
for the trophy of spider-man although
that could be part of it but he's just
it for the kill just in it for the
[ __ ] kills and like you know you show
his just like his home up front has
animal heads and [ __ ] in the home behind
the home as human heads mounted to the
wall and [ __ ] like that
that'd be dark but dope very metal same
kind of awesome yeah yeah I've read it
[ __ ] ugly I don't know if Disney
would go for that but yeah that'd be my
kind of thing excellent points give it
up well done
that was fun I like that like [ __ ] a
nice variation of Q and eggs you get to
hear from everybody else and like
revisit parts of the movies and stuff
like that oh that was neat we are out of
content for the night ladies and
gentlemen's you have a good time this
evening don't forget we're doing this
July 23rd 23rd tickets are already on
sale Nate did these wonderful prints for
the show so fine Nate and buy print
signed by me mark and Nate himself and
they it's got pins as well the fat men
beyond pins grab them if you want those
San Diego comic-con is in a couple weeks
we won't gather until after that so I'll
be putting up on my Twitter feed
Instagram feed anywhere you can find me
I'm sure mark will be same same there
and whatnot if you haven't seen
spider-man far from home [ __ ] are you
doing go out and see it right now if you
can't go see it in screen X cuz we all
did and we [ __ ] loved it man thanks to
the good folks at screen X for free
tickets walk in Brett Deacon and that is
fat man be on for this week I'm KO [ __ ]
I forgot something we can't do the show
without the guy to my left give it up
for mr. mark barnard Eddie it's fat man
be on for this week I'm Kevin Smith I'm
mark when tune in next week same fat
time same fat channel smart guest calm
or youtube.com slash Kevin Smith for the
good of all Creegan is John
[Applause]
[Music]
you